I had to take 20 hits because at the swap scenes.
He gets a free win!
Round 3.
Please.
Leave me alone.
I'm playing quick play.
because I don't want to lose Shinri.
I didn't want to lose Shinri before this stream.
Round 4.
Fight!
To be alone!
Yay!
I'm blocked.
Goodbye.
I won a quick play game.
Let's go.
all right nice okay yes i am now shinry all right all right
okay all right i'm ready i'm ready for the yoshi i'm ready
no no no no no no no no no no no i didn't forget i i got the
shinry I'm rinked up.
I'm like two rings.
Oh, Shinri-yu.
Shinri-yu.
It's the same.
Okay, I'm going into the main menu now.
I didn't forget.
Hey, hey, hey.
Not feeling good today?
I feel so good.
I'm not going to throw up.
Ready to go.
Yeah, totally.
I didn't already.
I feel so good.
Did you throw up from the pressure already?
No, no, no.
Yeah.
How are you feeling pressured?
You literally got coached, Matt.
You actually got coached this time.
I'm always pressured.
It's Sunday.
You rise again on Sunday.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready for you.
Where's slime?
The reason I was going to come here earlier and warm up, but
I was just watching the melee restream with slime all
morning.
What?
Yeah, I was watching Gommel 2.
I can't believe it.
You guys are not serious.
Dude, don't worry.
I was...
Okay, that's okay.
I was practicing.
Me, slime, or Kony just needs to lose one so we can force
Brawl Pro to play a game.
Why do you want to force that?
Why are we forcing it?
Because somebody didn't take it seriously.
Because you got to earn it.
You got to earn it.
You fucking watched a different stream instead of help
coaching us.
You're going to slide off me, Doki, and slime.
Yeah, you got mooch off of us?
I'm going to make sure Groomey hits every shot.
I'm just going to throw him.
He's just going to throw him on purpose.
Mine will be, oh, such a sad accident.
All the funny moves.
Key charge in front of them.
Dude, I was playing Jack in Quick Play yesterday.
That character is so fucking funny.
He just, he has so many stupid moves that you would never
do.
I love him.
Yeah, he's goofy.
Maybe that could be your number two.
I think I would like him more than Paul.
I played a little bit of Paul, and he's good, but I think
you have to be good at the game.
I think I could just do done on the shit with Jack.
You know?
And that'd be good.
I wish there were hero bands in Tekken.
Hero bands.
God, I've got that overarching ring rod.
I know that's you.
Could you imagine the level of play in this tournament if
there were, it would all just be like one twos.
People would just be hitting one twos.
over and over.
See?
Oh, wait.
What?
While standing.
There you go.
And then remember, Gumi's gonna mash after two.
So you gotta forward two one after.
Remember?
Okay.
I matched it.
Remember your forward two one after?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Two elbow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because she'll mash after your Punisher.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
No slimes here but then.
Yes.
Just like that.
And from a distance.
It's okay.
That's why we're here.
No!
Okay.
See, this is why I knew this before our game.
She's grunting like she's getting hit in real life.
Yeah.
Oh, come on!
How come I couldn't get that?
There you go.
Fucking warm up right here.
Yeah, see, see, I'm warming up the fingers.
Okay, this is not fair.
All right, and then she also does that a lot.
Yeah!
That's right!
Okay, that's not right.
I think she'll do it again after meeting you.
That's not right.
No, they don't stream every match.
Not?
Okay.
Yeah, so it's gonna be one side of the bracket.
I don't know.
I'll have to chat, I guess.
Oh.
While setting four after you duck it and the back three.
Okay.
Or, yeah.
Just while setting four and then back three.
Alright.
Do you know while setting four?
The one you're doing to punish this with.
Yeah.
Um, when you dug, just do it again.
Okay.
Or that.
I mean, you can do that if you want to.
if you're up for it.
That.
Okay.
What?
I mashed, though.
Sometimes it doesn't register when I mash.
Okay, do it far.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
And remember that step, too.
That's a good way to make space.
Yeah.
see i can learn do it again do it again the jaguar step and
then it's back three plus four yeah and that then that's
what sets up for your running knee gumi will duck a lot when
you're running up on earth so you gotta do that knee into
the into the shoulder okay into your l3 or whatever that
yeah that one just hold forward and just mash that out yeah
i'm learning wait why are you wait no no way I would never I
would never do that to the coach I would never yeah exactly
wait what how come I can't do that okay yeah how did you get
yours over mine you have just right when you block you don't
even have to block him just yeah just mash what's for I
smashed it Yeah, it's an OS.
I've matched it!
There's no way!
It's only on block that you can mash it though.
Yes, yes, Agumi will mash after so you can forward to one
her right away.
Boom, boom, yeah, she's gonna get hit by that.
And then remember after that, then you can run up into all
your bullshit.
And yeah, your meat stuff, everything.
Okay.
No, come on!
Come on!
Okay.
Oh my god.
What's up, Matt?
Are they starting?
Should be starting.
Oh, they didn't, yeah.
I'm just saying, because we gotta figure out, uh, where
we're gonna fight, and then check the engines.
She'll do it again.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, no!
I got confused.
Why are you streaming Tekken and not Tekken A?
She'll do it again.
in one?
Yeah, you're streaming Tekken.
No caps.
Just Tekken.
Okay.
I got it.
Theme, we might be cooked.
What do you mean?
That's okay.
You know what?
I accept my fate.
I'm just kidding, dude.
I'm just joking.
I'm trying my best.
You gotta mix it up.
You gotta mix it up because now I'm thinking about the spin.
You can't just keep doing the same thing see now i can't
block this now you you're doing fine you gotta mix it up see
now yeah oh my god
all right okay all right no no you got this oh no now i
don't feel that god anymore oh yeah and remember when we
talked about how to wake up off the floor too yeah like one
or two and instead of don't roll forward or you can just
hold back sometimes but generally just hit one or two to get
up and then when you get up hold back after okay yeah yeah
just like that that's a good way to get up wait why can't
luck okay
yeah good job i'm doing it don't i i i i panicked okay okay
don't if you duck this do the same thing the while standing
four the same okay after you duck let's see my fingers
reflexively go to three Yeah, but I'll go for it.
I'll try four again.
Okay.
Standing four.
So, can you do while standing four just in a neutral?
Like, if you crouch and like that?
Yeah?
That, yeah, that.
Yeah.
That's after we duck, that's what you basically let go
crouch and you hit.
Yeah.
Basically.
Okay.
And then after that, you can do back three.
If you hop kick after it, sometimes it's not going to work.
Okay.
And then you can back three there.
your tornado oh no i honestly yeah yeah even if you don't
get the full punish as long as you're not getting hit by
that it's still yeah still pretty good yeah and she'll
always do it again remember every time so block after she
heat engages and then duck
you can even back three off of standing forward too even if
you get that kick yeah or yeah you can do that too
yeah and then you do the jaguar bomb the ender yeah there
you go oh fuck okay and you can take your time with the
ender yeah you don't have to you know yes yes yeah oh god no
Here we go.
Alright.
And then remember, you have, in this range right here, you
have a good whiff punish that's a forward two one.
If you see them whiffing shit, yeah, it's a good move in
like a mid range at this level.
And then again, she's gonna start doing this from afar.
Okay, okay.
My mind didn't process it.
Okay, I'm ready.
It's three things.
Yeah.
Pop kick.
Pop kick before you think you have to.
Okay.
It's not easy.
Fuck this, I'm doing this.
This is easier.
And then you can do the two kicks after and then back three.
Okay, try it.
It's easier.
That's easier.
Yeah.
Oh, what?
Okay, whatever.
Oh, that didn't work.
What?
Yeah, that move sucks, and I'm not gonna lie.
So much!
You're doing good against it.
Yes.
Oh, are you on your new PC now?
We didn't lag at all.
Um, I fixed it.
Wait, what?
IT, don't see.
I fixed it.
Oh, yeah.
And remember, you got the back three one plus two.
Pretend it's like a string and hit that.
Back three one plus two, remember?
Okay, back three one plus two.
Okay.
2-1.
Pretend it's a string and it should work or match it out.
Oh, no, that's not it.
You know that back three and it leads into the leg drop,
remember?
Yeah.
Try that.
Okay.
No.
You can just hold one position.
two afterwards try that doki if you back three one plus two
and you just hold it after back three maybe it's easy yeah
yeah what's your okay they're starting now all right okay
there you go shoulder after remember yeah yeah that thing
it's gonna it's gonna destroy people i just can't get it the
timing correctly okay now put me on the other side please
thank you all right are they starting okay i'm gonna watch
who are you watching um watch the main channel who is who is
playing on the main stream you can watch that i'm gonna do
warm-up games on my other monitor i guess i'll pull up the
matches for my stream all right who do who do we watch guys
while i practice too it sucks because No one fucking plays
Yoshi.
I literally, every time I rank when I find a Yoshi player, I
just be like, please fight me.
Streams like Gumi, she's too low Elo to fight me.
I'm sorry, this has to mean, like, like in the rank.
I can't fucking get into her rank matches.
Unless she does, like, I do plus, I do minus plus two.
And I'm Shinri-U right now.
So, like, I play against Vanquisher and which one is it i
like because i have a i strictly do like only within two of
my ranks and i don't think she's within two of my ranks at
the moment it's not toxic i can't literally catch stream
state the rank is goomy she's on destroyer okay she's on
destroyer oh she's playing now all right let's It's not
toxic.
I literally can't stream Snipe her in rank.
But I'm watching it right now.
I'm watching how...
Oh my gosh.
Amore's being the shit out of Agumi.
Like, what is she doing?
Because, like, I always... The only thing that she fucks me
up on is the spin.
That's literally it.
It's the fucking spin.
Doki, yeah, you gotta play one of these two.
Yeah, I'm surprised.
Like, what is Amore doing?
That's different from what I was doing.
Oh, she knows combos.
That's what's different.
She actually knows combos.
Damn!
Oh my god.
My god, why can't I do that?
She's not doing the spin?
Wait, what?
She is.
Wait, Amore's going crazy.
Oh.
my god she actually knows combos dude did you see that that
combo she did kony doesn't even do that one what the fuck
she knows combos that's crazy how is that possible
round one all right
oh my gosh wait what i wish i know combos
I know this, though.
That's all I need to know.
Okay, maybe not.
Maybe not.
I'm so sorry.
That's not all I need to know.
You're right.
Oh, my God.
Maybe he's not!
Oh, maybe I need no more than it!
Oh, goodbye.
Oh wait, what?
Okay.
Okay, I'm surprised.
Oh my god, he low parries that.
It's like he knows.
Is the truth.
Okay, that's fine.
It's not fair.
How do all these players know combos?
Like, how do you stay in tenure knowing all these combos
when I can abuse certain stuff to shin you all i'm saying is
like i don't know if i don't know combos and i can get to
this rank in one week maybe these players are oh yeah
yesterday in rank i bumped into a in rank i had to fight a
purple and like they were like a ttv so then i looked at
their ttv and i was like and then I looked at their VODs and
it took them like uh one month of playing because they were
like hard stuck like red for like so long and then and then
they recently like yesterday got to purple and it took them
like a month straight of playing Tekken to get there and I'm
like bro what it took me one week to get to red
I feel like if I commit a another week, maybe I'll learn how
to get to... Because they were... I was like looking at
their vibes, and I was like, oh shit, they're their skill
and she was... I was just like...
I was like, they would play rank every day for a month
straight from red to purple.
Playing... Bro, that guy was a king player!
He can't say that!
Don't you definitely stay aggressive against her?
That guy was a king player so i was like watching because i
was like oh hey a fellow king who's in purple let me see
your fucking thing
getting the purple is the wall he's playing king wrong bro i
fucking hate fighting all the okay this one's new okay I
swear, every time I see arena player, I'm just like, I'm
done.
I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
I'm so tired of playing against all the arenas.
Thank God this is quick play.
I really don't want to play rank right now.
I grinded rank a lot yesterday and I'm tired.
That's good.
I'm so happy.
I can play someone else.
I'm tired of playing against...
against all the fucking reyna's and paws and fucking uh
dragon laws like I'm tired I'm so tired and Alyssa's too I
won't play new characters I'm fine with playing as Claudio
if he's someone new I'm Scott get away from me I'm streaming
I'm streaming okay so glad to play against him Yeah,
because, like, his moves aren't fucking bullshit.
Like, like, I can actually get out of the moves later.
I say, like, look, see, I can actually get up.
My play against Raina, I, like, fucking, like, just not play
for, like, 20 minutes.
Say he's the king player, to be fair.
Say he's the king player.
Look, I'm just done.
at the other wall no my other wall yeah time to correctly
oh nice okay nice goodbye
oh no no no please leave me alone leave me alone no take me
back to the other side I don't like being on the side.
They don't know.
I can't play.
I literally cannot play on this side.
Like, it's actually so bad.
If they put me on this side, I'm helpless.
I'm like a sheep.
They don't know.
On this side, I'm scared.
The right side is where things go down.
I just don't know how to Like, okay, like my brain can't
fucking reverse the input.
That's the thing.
I have to reverse the input, and I don't know how to do
that.
Get ready for the next battle.
I don't know how to reverse inputs.
Well, I say that before.
Because then they have to take me to the other side.
They gotta figure out how to put me on the other side.
They gotta figure it out first.
how to put me there because it's usually i put myself there
that's the thing i put myself out on the other side it's
usually not like usually not the enemy team that does it
it's me oh my god please i'm so sorry yeah i saw goomy one
yo matt yeah what's up dude um are you watching not really
what's going on it's kind of crazy why what happened i don't
know these two girls just now are insane oh goomy versus a
more i have no way of the monitor yeah Oh, please, please,
leave me alone.
Please, just a helpless king player.
Leave me alone.
Know what I'm doing.
This is my first fighting game.
You've been playing fighting games your whole fucking life.
Oh, oh, what the?
I'm just a silly joke.
Jaguar!
Oh fuck, I missed it.
She's- I'm streaming!
Leave me alone!
How do you know that?
You can tell.
Because he knows combos.
The most- New fighting players don't know what- People who
never play fighting games barely register your combos we
just fucking click we just press the buttons that we know
works
we just learn combos no that's just you no no all i'm saying
is if you know combos and you're still in shinri then like
you've been a fighting player for so long because like
because you just do the you just listen to what let all the
guides tell you to you know what i mean you're you don't
come up with your own strategies to climb the ranks you like
follow what the sheep you're like a sheep so you follow what
they tell you to do because it's what's right it's what's
always been but like those who are new to fighting games
they like see and don't like have like don't have like
background in fighting games we basically we come up with
our own strategies that we see that works and then abuse it
until it stops working and then we have to come up our new
with new strategies but people with fighting game experience
they just come in doing the same combos over and over and
over again and like doing the like the foundation stuff
because they're taught from fighting game experience that
that is how to do like that is like what you have to do to
climb and if i can just abuse simple buttons and just not
knowing what the fuck i'm doing and get to this elo that
means i'm not from this i'm not from this community
okay no
nice goodbye goodbye
oh shit goodbye to me oh please i have a registered pattern
yet you can get stuck playing assert you can get stuck yeah
but the thing is i just need to learn a new new new cheese
that's it every time i learn a new cheese like i climb like
and i just need to learn a new cheese in this elo it just
works
Oh, fuck.
Oh, whoops.
Whoa.
Stop.
Oh, fuck.
He didn't stop.
Why didn't you stop?
I don't understand.
Oh!
Stop!
Oh.
Nice.
Got that.
Boom!
Okay.
Yeah!
Stop!
It's true.
I just needed... Whoa!
But does that stop from there?
No!
Wait, what?
How?
Whoa!
Yeah, wait, yeah, wait.
Whoa, he ducked.
Cat's duck forever!
BAM!
Because I play king.
That's fucking right!
Stay on the ground!
Nobody likes you!
Not even your mom!
Not get Ali kicked to death.
I don't even earn Elo for that.
I've tried because I hate you.
There.
okay guys look at look at like we were checking out our play
data look at my defense guys wait where is it performance
stats look at my
It's so bad It's so bad
We were We were comparing our These defense Our stats to
people And it's so bad
What the fuck is this?
How the fuck do people how the fuck do people let me get
away with this?
How do people let me climb to this?
Look this is the tech in a community's fault for putting me
for letting me climb this high exactly why do I need defense
if I could just kill them you have been enabled look at that
it's just that easy
Yeah, never need to learn throw text if I'm doing the
throwing.
That is so true.
That is so fucking true.
I don't know any throw.
Like, I don't know how to do any tech stuff.
All I do is grapple.
Grapple.
Only coward.
Yeah, except...
Accept your throws.
Accept your fate.
You know what you're getting into.
Just lie back and think of Paris.
While I throw you to the fucking ground.
Exactly.
Take the throw!
Oh, shit.
Sir.
Please.
All I know, I don't know how to D.
Take this.
That's fucking it.
right yes right and this and this oh okay you actually you
don't block okay so okay so that's good to know that's good
to know you don't duck like i like that that's the king's
dream right there
take my throw yeah and again oh wait sorry oh shit sorry he
doesn't want me to throw him i don't know why why won't you
want me to fucking throw you people fucking line up for that
oh my god he's staying on the ground now it's like a
lifetime opportunity yay stay on the ground why is she
getting away with it that's what i'm saying a lot of these
fighting players in this elo they have the sheep tell them
to do and because of that they don't know what to do when
someone does something different as in five alley kicks in a
row it's just so up they're just they're they're so confused
they're like what how is she letting you get away with this
you just don't know they're so confused when people do that
because it's so unorthodox so i just like abuse the stuff
that they don't are not used to watching in turn this kind
of oh he does that same move over and over again get let me
let me breathe let me breathe let me breathe oh my god
that's right oh you counted that that's not fair oh you
counted that too That's fine.
Oh, shit.
It's not fine.
Question?
Whoa.
That's my move.
Okay.
He does that all the time.
Whoa.
Nice.
And then I do that.
And then I rush in.
Wait, what?
There you go.
See that?
You like that little spin?
I did.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Oh, I still have this.
I didn't even realize I still have my heat.
Oh, no.
No.
I pressed the wrong button.
Oh, it's fine.
He pressed the wrong button, too.
Oh, my God.
It's so fucked up.
It would be a shame if he died like this.
Goodbye.
Fucking go back to yellow rank.
And you don't get a rematch.
Get outplayed.
Yay!
Yippee!
Okay.
Ugh!
Not toxic at all.
Oh my god, a fellow king player.
Show me.
This is going to be a king player to actually know his
combos.
Oh my god.
He actually knows how to do that.
Oh, he jumped.
I should have.
I need to know how to remember to.
Oh my god.
He did that thing.
My coach keeps telling me to do.
My god.
That's fucking right.
You should learn how to do that too Oh shit.
Oh shit.
Never mind.
I'm a king player.
I don't know how to tech I don't know how to tech that
Oh, is he doing That sidestep he fucking knows It's not
fair.
You're also a king You know what I want to do That's fucking
right.
Oh, that's not right.
He threw me away
Oh my god He's doing he's doing all the kick stuff I would
do back to me Who is he?
He's in my mind What the fuck is actually in my mind?
Oh my god!
He's fucking rock paper scissoring me correctly!
That's actually crazy!
See, this is a king player that knows this shit.
But yeah, it's still an vanquisher, so that's embarrassing.
You clearly know what you're doing!
How are you in this Elo?
You're losing it.
I don't know how he's in this vanquisher.
If he can do all that and he's still stuck in vanquisher.
Bad matchup exists too.
Okay, if bad matchup exists, how would they let me into this
Elo?
I could not get all good matchups for this.
That's all I'm saying.
That's all I'm saying, guys.
Boop.
I lost, therefore, you should be embarrassed.
If you could do all of that, and you're still here, you're
still in vanquishing?
That's probably like his second...
Why would you create Smurf accounts for this?
Don't you need to pay for it?
Don't you need to buy more Tekken?
Oh, I guess if you play on console, you don't have to.
That makes sense.
If you play on console, you don't have to create new Smurf
accounts.
I was just thinking like, that's crazy.
To still win.
that's true his power level was like 145 he must have been
like a god or something in his main character and this was
just his side project
okay i know like this move and then and then i've tried to
do this correctly but i always fuck it up because it's like
there's no scenario where people would let me do that I
don't know when I can do this.
It's not fair.
Boom.
Like, this is a...
Oh, and then I can do this.
Yay!
Remember your training?
I am.
I'm trying my best.
I'm scared.
I haven't been nervous at all throughout this event until
now.
This is where I've never been so nervous before.
Yay!
No, because now that it matters.
Before it didn't really matter, now it matters.
Remember to block with one.
What, my 30 fucking block?
Watch this.
Oh!
Oh, he blocked too.
It was cool for a second, though.
Not gonna lie, it was pretty cool when I did make it work,
though.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I don't know his fucking moose!
Oh.
here get over here oh shit let me back on the other side oh
oh no oh no he punished me oh no he punished me no let me
back up let me back up no okay bye I think he blocks that
yeah I was gonna say I'm pretty sure he would like
fucking...
That's right!
Ellie kick, Ellie kick, Ellie kick!
Ellie kick!
Oh!
I'm sorry!
I didn't mean to Ellie kick you 20 times!
But what if I do it again?
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
oh my god please leave me alone wait what i don't slam that
oh oh he blocks it oh i should have roc them or rdk him does
he block what how is he so fast someone check this man's
system make him pee in the cup
I'm not mashing.
I have a strategic way of doing my buttons.
Oh, mashing can't get me this.
Oh, I can't remember he's faster than me always.
He's always faster than me.
So it sucks.
Oh.
No, I fucked it up.
that up too!
There you go.
I didn't fuck this up.
Goodbye.
Wait, he's Keishan?
You're fucking trash.
If you can be Keishan, I can be Keishan too.
I got That was fucking blue?
Imagine losing.
Oh my god.
I beat all fucking blue.
Embarrassing.
You should uninstall the game, bro.
If your whole life was Tekken 8 and you let that happen to
you, you should uninstall.
My OG can't be this tough thing.
all I'm saying all I'm saying I don't know I don't know yeah
beat a blue stop making people quit I shouldn't rename my
name doking uninstall now oh no Oh, this is where I get
absolutely destroyed by the better king player.
Yeah, I had a feeling he knew about our...
He would know about the fucking...
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god, he's an actual king player!
Boop!
He should uninstall Tekken now!
Oh, he did that thing.
I can do that, too.
Oh, I want to do that.
Oh, see, I can mirror you.
Oh, that was an accident.
But, oh, my God, I teched it.
How?
Good question.
Yeah.
Oh, no, I teched it, too.
No, I didn't tech that.
Boop.
Bro, this is, like, the slowest fucking king player ever.
I swear to God.
get this i had a feeling yeah i swear this is the slow i've
never seen a king player play this slow
it's actually crazy how how slow of a king player he is
a king player that thinks no way
no way
That's actually so rare, man.
He's doing his part.
That's what I'm saying.
I've never fucking seen a king player play this slow before.
Kings are always so...
Especially, like, mirror match kings, too.
I guess, like...
Oh, wait, no.
The Kony matchup was so fucking slow.
to be fair the kony matchup with what's his name g uh that
guy the the other king player that he played he that was
such a slow king matchup oh i won i'm the better king you
play too slow man
you played yeah jim shen yeah yeah
Way too fucking slow.
Yay.
Alright, here we go.
He's almost blue and cat tech shining wizard.
I swear, these purples and blue rings are fucking easier
than the red race.
I'm gonna say that I'm absolutely destroyed by these
purples.
Thank you for taking me back to the side.
Oh, bro, you duck.
I'm going to say that.
And now I'm going to get absolutely destroyed by this guy.
Oh, no.
Leave me alone.
Oh, goodbye.
This guy actually knows what he's doing.
Oh no.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean it.
Oh, he has four wins.
He's actually serious.
Whoa, he's actually serious.
Oh, he ducks everything!
But you can't duck this!
Oh god.
Oh god, never mind.
You don't need a duck.
You can just beat the shit out of me.
Understandable.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Understandable.
You hate... You hate tigers.
You hate jaguars.
Oh shit.
Goodbye.
I guess I'll go to the moon now.
My people need me.
Oh!
He fucking went first!
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
This is my sorry punch.
I didn't mean to.
Oh shit.
No.
I'm so sorry.
Please.
Have mercy.
Hey.
Okay, but will he expect this?
Oh my god!
Who are you?
Does he attack it?
No, he doesn't.
Oh, no, I've messed it up.
Boom!
JK.
You're right, maybe not again.
You're right, you're right.
Maybe not.
Can I please get up?
Please, sir.
Please.
Please, please.
All right, I deserve that.
I'm sorry for...
the 500 shining wizards I'm so sorry oh my god I'm so I'm
sorry for all those shining wizards I didn't mean to I'm so
sorry what's my bad
I got so cocky.
Yeah.
I got humbled.
I mean, there's a reason why my block is at 30.
Okay, I'm going to block in this one.
All right.
I'm going to block on this one.
Oh, no.
She's a fast one, too.
They always have that ghost.
How do you guys register the fact that I don't block those.
I guess when you abuse alley kicks, that's when you know.
Oh.
No, I even fucking... I even tried to block.
I was actually trying to block.
What?
No!
My chat told me to try blocking, and I always knew that was
a mistake!
I'll never block again.
My chat was fucking wrong.
Oh my god.
I think the issue is that I don't know what move is what.
What is low and what isn't.
That's definitely my issue.
Oh,
she doesn't block that though.
Let's go.
Does she do it again?
Okay.
Oh.
Unlucky.
Goodbye, she grabbed my nipples.
Goodbye.
See ya, block!
Oh.
Yo, we got a coach match.
No, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Both teams are playing Coach Mash.
I'm watching.
Oh, God.
Leave me alone.
That's crazy.
Shift your butt.
Yeah!
Goodbye.
Oh, it's a Coach tiebreaker?
Oh, shit.
I hope I don't forget everything.
No.
Nice.
I take that one point off of purple.
You're a purple?
That's embarrassing for you.
That's so embarrassing.
You should be blocking that if you're a purple.
Okay.
All right, I'm sorry.
But you should be blocking that.
This is gonna be close, dude.
Oh No, no, I swear I was at a low.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for making fun of you.
I'm so sorry.
I'm not
No Okay, I'll take those.
Oh That's okay.
I took two rounds off a fucking purple E-rank now you should
be in my E-Lo
You should be be in my Ilo for making that too close.
That's some fucking bullshit right now.
Yeah, that's way too close.
Yeah, like what?
I actually have 50 hours.
I was looking at how many hours I have.
I have 50-ish hours.
Yeah, I have very weak defense.
The thing is, a lot of the characters I'm playing, like a
lot of people I'm playing against, like, the worst part is,
like, it's because they're, like, such uncommon characters
in rank, so I barely play against these types of characters.
I think that's, like, the worst part, honestly.
Oh, hey, it's Leon.
Because, like, I fucking...
I saw, like, fucking...
my entire time in those 50 hours getting to this elo like
all the fucking ranks i's like you know from from beginner
to red i've saw three yoshis i saw only three yoshis but i
saw fucking 200 fucking uh reina so
like that's the worst part
Kings were also pretty rare.
I think kings were like...
I think I've seen like maybe like in rank.
Maybe like...
Oh, Chesto.
Okay.
I'm trying to like think.
I think I've seen like maybe like 8 king players.
10?
I think 10.
10 king players.
King shows up more later on.
Yeah.
I fucking see like 200 reynas.
200 reynas.
Who else do I see a lot?
I see a lot of Alyssa's too.
Okay.
Oh, I fucked up the... I fucked that up.
I can do it again.
There you go.
I'm ready to rock.
I got, um, blue three back.
I'm warmed up.
The kings and the Yoshis are in the high rings.
Yeah, but it sucks because I don't get a chance to practice.
I see a lot of Azus too.
like let's just fucking play some video games dude let's
play some video game that's it take me back to the other
side all we have to do nice yeah oh wait you fucking rose oh
this guy knows how to play against kings and heroes and all
the guy knows how to play against kings holy shit he
actually rose
I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, chat.
I'll be right back.
I need to use the bathroom.
You just get to see King and Yoshi.
You're standing there.
Well, he almost knows how to play against Kings.
Not that.
What was it?
Matching settings.
All right.
I'll be right, guys.
Who's here?
What's up?
We're fighting team NYK.
They had to do a coach match tiebreaker for it.
Yep.
That's a five?
No.
Oh, that's crazy.
I was saying you guys watching this, right?
I just watched both.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm back.
I wasn't watching the Lily mirror.
He had like crazy scaling, so it looked like he was going to
have to win one more interaction.
All right.
And then he got like a wall reset.
I'm going to have to reset the scaling.
and he just blew her up with one move i don't know what it
was but oh he was in heat was it like the mid where she
spins in the air and i don't think so it looked like a like
a oh hold on watch punch someone someone linked it i'm
watching it i i was like okay so the scaling means he can't
get the kill here and then he like bounced off wall it was
like oh okay that's like 19 i think holy he came back like
this yeah dude all right hope kick do your thing do your
thing Do your thing.
Another hope kick.
Oh, no.
No.
Oh, what the hell?
Miles got up incorrectly there.
She could attack, but...
That's what that was.
I'm pretty... That's not guaranteed.
Let me see it again.
Yeah, she could attack right there.
Okay.
She could have got up.
I think.
I don't know.
This game's still kind of new.
i brought you on the sage amp thing too yeah it hits against
wall that's so weird that's a weird situation yeah yeah
maybe it was guaranteed i'm not sure you can hold back i
think if she texts she could have got out of it all right um
yeah the teams are playing kind of crazy i mean i believe in
you bro so am i you are also you didn't play with us
yesterday we had a big session oh yeah i had i'd fucking
clock in for my other job i feel good i feel good i feel
good i just got it i ranked up again just now everything
everything's fucking nice man big big ryjin i'm a big ryjin
gaming it was good you you kept josh from practicing though
that was good i i actually did i know
makes sense he needed to talk about me i mean you also kept
me from practicing too i'm not gonna that's not my fault you
watching my stream is not my fault it is your fault you guys
i'm like i gotta go practice and you're like practice you
pay your editor in triple number guys what's the moveset for
it so there what's the do you guys know the moveset for it
oh i'm kishin oh no It's fine.
Do you even want to go to Evo?
Who?
Me?
Is my...
No, that's not...
Oh, Doki.
Yeah!
You do?
Okay.
Yeah!
So you guys better win!
Her ass is not going to Evo.
What?
What's the best way to...
I don't know how you do it.
Is it like a super chat?
No, I want free tickets here.
I want free tickets.
Yeah, it's not as good.
Paying your own ticket is not as good as a free ticket.
yeah getting comped from Seijam like it's the fucking Aria
run me my $40 spirit fight yeah wait are they actually
paying for plane tickets too yeah oh wait and hotels yeah
what the fuck win this for me run me I'm trying to run you
your middle seat that you deserve I deserve this I love free
stuff
I'm seeing a lot of discourse on the timeline About throwing
chairs Dude he It was a big row I saw it I thought he broke
the stage Because he was like all like folded and shit But
apparently he was like that Are we supposed to get on to the
room now or not Yeah they're making a lobby in a second I'm
gonna go pee One second
Kumi's like, I'm ripping off this shirt if I lose a round.
Our friendship of eight years will be over for this match.
It was time.
It was a timer and this was it.
I...
Yo, he fucked that chair up, dude.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I know, dude.
It ran its course.
It's time to end it on Tekken 8.
I have never felt so nervous.
before.
I know, right?
Like, why is this so?
Yeah.
Wait, Doki, you said you've never been this nervous before?
No, I've never been this nervous before.
Never in your life.
No one has ever felt that way that I feel right now.
It's true.
The science needs to study this new feeling.
Yeah, this new feeling.
What is this feeling?
Dude, this stage slam is pretty stressful, yeah.
I mean, it's like really good and really bad.
all together like a roller coaster that we've heard of hey
we'd be feeling much worse if we didn't all have trips
obviously we want to get her a trip you know what i'm saying
yeah you guys should feel particularly bad if i don't get a
trip yeah james praying for us to win so he doesn't have to
double up he should give i told him he should give like you
guys like a budget equivalent to the evo ticket yeah wait a
minute that's kind of yeah give us 500 for the tables.
Yeah, exactly.
Each?
I mean, how much is it?
How much is like hotel, flight, and ticket?
Add that all together.
Each of us gets a budget.
Yeah, we get a per diem, a lobster dinner every night.
Oh, true, true, true.
It's sweet, dude.
The hotel room has to be an upgrade.
If you guys win, we should upgrade our hotel rooms to a
suite.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I want the heart tub, and I want a cup.
tub i'll get in the heart tub with the champagne glass okay
oh it's the sazana we're in now we'll join right after this
match oh i've
never been this stressed before i know scary the first one
was really bad too yeah it's okay though it's fun though
yeah and we'll do a little food drive donation drive thing
for you okay all right guys if i lose this is because of my
coach yeah the box in front of the grocery store will put
like canned pumpkin in there yeah i will get you to evo my
coach just didn't coach me hard enough it's his fault it's
not my fault he's a king player too yeah i know that's like
the worst A king player couldn't fucking help me.
Oh, he deafened himself.
He doesn't want it.
His ass is just trying to hear that.
Not today.
100% blaming the coach on this.
Oh my god.
He's just gonna beat me up, guys.
Just remember the spinny shit.
I'm gonna try.
You got it.
We believe in you.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Oh, what?
Yes.
Yep.
Good stuff.
Nice.
I'm coming.
Oh, God.
She's doing that thing.
Okay.
Full screen reset.
She's doing that thing.
The spinny thing.
Okay.
I die here.
Oh, no, I die here.
Round two.
It's alright.
Just one round.
We lock in, we lock in.
Wait, what?
Good shit!
Let's fucking go.
Yeah, but it like didn't register.
It's okay.
As long as you're not getting hit.
Oh, she like...
Yes!
Good shit.
Yeah, it doesn't matter if you're not punishing as long as
you're blocking and not taking damage.
Oh my god.
Don't hit me.
Oh my god, you're a genius.
Okay.
Good stuff.
This is it.
Nice.
That is it.
That's good job.
That was sick.
Good shit.
It's a round of the bank.
You probably can hit that every round because Gumi's not
respecting it.
rip it okay nice good shit it's cool oh good check i love
the dick jab good job oh no good stop
that's okay that was a great round i know you lost it about
it yeah it's a good round You played that round very well.
Yeah.
Fundamentally.
Nice.
Oh.
It's cool.
I keep forgetting that.
Helicopter will grab you like that.
I think she hits me.
Oh, huge.
She hit this.
Yeah.
And you have heat.
Run up.
Yeah, actually.
That's big.
She'll duck after she blocks it so you can hit her with the
square.
okay okay yes no no i don't think i don't nice try though
nice try yeah i didn't buffer it before yeah all good very
close though yeah yeah that's a good match and you played
your gameplay you played it well it just you know she got a
couple more hits on you yeah this is actually so so doable
yeah
uh It's all good, it's all good.
Gamer time.
Gamer's only, from here on out.
Only gamers.
It's all for gamers, don't worry.
Good stuff.
Okay.
Unlucky.
Nice.
Good grab.
Oh, he wants to press buttons so bad.
This Yoshimitsu.
Okay.
Good stuff, good weight.
Oh, I don't hit this.
Oh, I do!
Yeah, I think you win.
Yeah, that does too much damage.
Well, blam.
Hell yeah.
Nice.
No, you can block that.
Oh, okay.
No, she counter-blocked.
That's fine.
You got the hit.
Nice.
Another one.
Good wizard.
Nice.
Yes, medic!
Oh my god, let's go!
Let's go!
Oh my god!
That was crazy.
Blast him!
Bring it home, bring it home.
The dokey alley kicks.
You're in your fucking element!
Okay.
Good stuff!
Oh no.
Great, great block.
Patience is fine, great block.
Yes!
You're doing so good.
That's so fucking awesome.
Good blocks!
Aww.
Alright, it's alright.
It's cool, it's one round.
This is a fucking, this is Tekken.
Yeah.
This is learning Tekken, 100%.
Oh,
she realized I know her counter.
What the fuck was that?
Hidden Jutsu?
Nice try.
Okay.
Some Naruto shit.
What the fuck?
That's alright.
Just run your shit.
Try your best.
There you go.
Love that.
Yes.
Oh my god.
Nice.
What?
A hit?
What's... Alright.
Nice.
Good grab.
Oh no, she got me.
I didn't heal it.
Oh.
Very close.
You ran your game.
You did great, honestly.
Oh, it's so close.
Yeah, I don't, I don't like to blow smoke, but that was
genuinely, that was good Tekken, and that's what happens.
And we'll clean this one up and then we'll go next.
Yeah, yeah.
At the evil run back, when Gumi is there, we'll all be lost.
Yeah.
be fucking loud in that room.
Yeah, I'll be like, no!
Fucking beat her ass!
I don't like what I've done differently there.
I feel like she, like, adapted so fast, too.
Yeah, she hit you with the Hello Rage Arts, so, like, I
guess just block, you know, call it out, and then you get a
full launch.
Yeah, and you blocked her lows perfectly.
We just have to mash the four, and you ducked her three one
thing too but again yeah press the four yeah but it was good
you were uh defensively you were doing great i should have
kicked more maybe i should have alex next next match and for
the future just send it like i don't it's alex don't listen
to coach you don't know what i'm talking about this pickman
thing is the funniest thing i've ever seen in my life he's
immune to fire by the
Mm-hmm.
Okay, it came down.
Nice.
Round two.
Oh,
nice.
Yes!
There you go.
We are alley kick central.
Bro, what?
When you block a back one, two, back one, two, him back.
it's unsafe or you can even duck the second and hop kick him
sick also
if you jab jab he's gonna dog you can jab that pop kick him
also after running three he's gonna duck every time right
now right yeah round four yeah fight another
ground three yeah boom yes
at every time see yeah yeah he's autopilot
no problem yeah i just noticed here yeah okay we know what
he's doing yeah jab jab mid and then running three mid
that's what you gotta do okay yep you got it you got this
brother round one fight
Yes!
He might stop now.
He might stop now, but it's up to you to recognize it.
Guaranteed.
Get up, bro.
Get up!
He's doing it every time.
It's an easy break.
Fuck.
I got anxious.
It's okay, it's okay.
Walk in, goat.
That lean is for you.
Slurp it up.
There's no way.
Mep, meow.
Okay.
Mogged it.
Fucking mugged Giga Chad like Jesus.
Fuck yeah.
Oh, he's dead, Tony.
Oh my god.
You can hold off of this.
Well, almost dead.
It's fine.
Nice.
Nice job.
I mean, Coney obviously mused, let's be honest here.
Yeah.
Man.
Yes.
Nice.
I haven't gone for that yet.
Let's fucking go, baby.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
He wants to get off that stage.
Even though, yeah, it's a good king stage, but he's also
king.
Yeah, I'm going to pin this.
You got the reeds, man.
Remember, Cody, back one two.
You go back one, two, and back.
Right.
Yeah, that just, if he hits you twice and you block it, wop,
wop, and he explodes.
optimal punish is to duck the second hit and hop kick him
for it but yeah if we have him practice it just punish it oh
good yeah and yeah he's still a ducker one one mid
boom baby nice
damn that was good yeah
Fuck, I tried to shiny wizard that.
Nice sprinkler.
Oh, wow.
That's bad.
I'm just mashing.
That's fine.
Reset.
Act like that didn't even happen.
That round did not happen.
He's not ducking anymore.
But now you poke, poke, grab.
Nice hop.
Nice.
He's done.
Fuck!
It's all good.
Oh, it's okay.
He's got this.
Come on, baby.
Ah, yo.
It's all right.
Yo.
Well done.
Come on, baby.
Oh, nice, Connie!
Fight.
Oh, my God.
He smashed plunders.
Look at that, damn.
Oh!
Oh He didn't take it Oh Wrap it up wrap it up.
Maybe that momentum.
Oh my gosh Fight
Nice grab You have heat
What else?
Oh my god, what else?
Oh my god No!
No!
You're hip, you're hip, you're hip, you're hip.
There's no way!
You're just different.
I can't believe it.
You're so much better!
You're just different.
Holy strike.
Ellie kept strike.
That's a new team name.
I can't believe it, dude.
That was incredible.
That was...
Oh my god.
That's right.
That king matchup.
how is it i just wasn't alley kicking enough i shouldn't
have left the next match let's just send it that's what if
it speaks to you i gotta put the cuff back on holy oh my god
dude so fucking okay let's go dude all right all right all
right a little bit too nerve-wracking holy shit no these are
hard to watch for sure man world's hardest watch was oh my
god that was like the slowest king matchup i've ever seen
it's so like it's like a chess game yeah dude they were
playing so like defensive oh coney you gotta press the yeah
oh i'm sorry yeah yeah you're good dude i think i pressed it
twice sorry god that's what i'm talking about i'm so they
played so defensive and like yeah that was incredible all
right hold on i'm gonna all right i wonder what his heart
rate wants in real yeah oh they gotta get heart rate
monitors first ajm slam 3.
bro his pop-off you gotta see it oh my god that was like so
close to you got this time to lock in brother you got this
easy kishin i believe
I miss round robin day
He continues to get up incorrectly
Nice Round two fight Fucking go slime put her at the fucking
wall good shit
what's the answer young lady eat her up fine it's fine it's
fine give it a second
we went neutral though you got strength but we went neutral
drew oh we got a spring kick we got a spring kick to get any
damage we got to do the destroyer shit okay Oh, damn!
Any damage, we need orange shreds.
Oh, shit!
Round three.
Can you get up here?
Nice!
Oh, wow.
Okay.
It's all good.
It's one round.
Yeah, you just give him one.
Slapper in the face.
one big whiff on a slide
nice is that real why does it lead into stuff it's a if you
block the low you can launch her for it
joshua here incredible
It should be.
Wall combo.
Okay.
Yeah, I come out sometime!
Oh no.
Oh!
Oh, close.
Close, very close.
I'm delaying a little bit.
Crazy good match.
oh you win
round one fight that's what i'm talking about here
but nice oh i
fucked up bad it's okay composure
Back the slime.
Damn it.
Um, you're alive.
Keep in mind if he's going to rage art once, he'll probably
send it again.
Alright, I have my mix up.
You ready?
What?
Why couldn't I get away?
Whatever.
It's all good.
Fight.
I'm panicking
No, nice job.
No, no more g plus.
I think she kills me here.
It's raging shit
You could have won that you ducked that high she did you
could have launched him for round three Fight Good fucking
hell, sweet
Nice Oh
Okay, so I can't G-pop that, it doesn't matter.
Yeah, I just got outmatched.
Good try, good try.
That's fine, dude.
Alright, Bravo, are you ready for your matchup soon?
What the fuck do you mean I could lose?
Man, don't say that!
I'm always, I'm ready, yes.
You ready to play against another bear?
This could be a legendary fucking comeback by this guy.
you got to get out of the lobby slime my friend
all right i'll try yep just play your best training is
already complete oh if you're wondering i did throw up by
the way oh no i guess that's just life it's just part of me
it's just at least one throw up for a slam my read down back
one and then I'm gonna do the fucking sweep you guys oh into
the stratosphere hold on I'm gonna hit a funny combo nothing
else matters it depends how funny it is it's pretty funny it
better be pretty fucking funny I read it is complete
Nice.
Good shit.
Well done.
Oh my.
Oh my god.
American.
American reset.
Well done.
Oh my god.
Oh, I hit one of those two.
Oh.
When he's in heat, he's going to run in this part of that.
Maybe walk around.
Round three.
.
oh i didn't know that okay all right upgrades scar got some
upgrades yeah scar yeah you're watching if you just punish
those things oh i know it's like the launch too hold on
oh my god i just got control that's okay own them for it
Nice.
He has his potion.
He has it.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Upgrades.
Just keeping it close.
That was the warm-up.
Round one.
Fight.
Oh Good shit nice Does that hurt Victor?
He doesn't need to have any kids anymore Oh send that dude.
Yeah, I'll launch
Punish Elliot.
Oh, he's He's okay
He's back online.
He is risen.
We adapt.
He is fucking risen.
It's okay.
Clean.
Nice.
boost heat still bounces still on the table that was his
heat smashing went for it too still got that yeah the floor
blast is still on oh i try to heat boost let's try let's try
nt and tnt and tnt still got time
oh my god he's out playing me i'm sorry yeah it's all good
it's all good you just keep it solid man Yeah, play your
game.
What the fuck, Skara?
Nice.
Oh, yes.
He has rage.
Oh, he's left.
He's dead.
We blocked that.
Nice.
Nice shot.
Good shit.
Oh, my God.
Go, Matt.
Come on, man.
I hate this asshole.
Lock in, young man.
Back to you.
Make him retire.
Change stage if you want.
No, I want it.
Yes, that's
right.
Nice.
Nice launch.
That's it.
Yeah!
Fucking go, Jack!
Let's go.
One!
Oh my god, what are these combos?
That's how many sets he's getting.
Fuck you.
That's fucking right!
My god.
This kills.
Jesus is omnipresent.
Omniscient.
He knows what lies into the heart.
He can see what's in your heart and your mind.
You have sin.
That was the biggest fuck you ever.
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, you confess to our Lord and Savior, Jack Jesus.
He cries for you.
Turns water to blood.
That move is so dumb.
Shining.
Nice.
Send the bomb.
That's the cost of heaven.
Message from...
god you've been lost that one kill him kill him let's go
let's go what are we doing that's right boom let's go for
that why do you do it did his brain oh my god i think i feel
like his heart's vortex tilted off let's go his higher
decision making like part of his brain just melted off like
an orange what the fuck was that man he threw a rod and then
the engine seized oh all right bra pro are you gonna stay
deaf into heavy focus brother we're sorry that we put you in
this spot you should be this is crazy i'm saying right here
you could have coached me better always come down
this could be this could be legendary you got this brother
come on baby i believe in you i mean match them again real
shit it's fine if you know no just treat it like a rank set
bro it's literally ranked and you're just farming points off
of my cake yeah yeah you bump into him in rank Steve donated
you like a thousand bits and it's just talking you like it's
just any other day wait he's on Steve yeah oh
nice oh that's new
Oh, nice.
Oh my god.
Got it.
Nice!
That's fucking right.
Round two.
Oh.
Bounce him.
Oh nice.
He's in the corner.
Oh, what a combo.
Steven.
Throw him that fucking one.
He's dead.
Oh, he's so good.
Holy shit.
It's alright.
There we go, baby.
I was like, isn't that elephant?
Oh, he dated.
yes that's wall oh my god that's gonna hurt nice oh that's
right oh wow true true that's crazy oh my god how did i kick
miss oh
you beat his ass honk put him on the wall yeah yeah yeah oh
What else?
Oh my goodness.
I think there's a reason we're the top team, dude.
I think there's a fucking reason we're the favorites.
How?
Oh my god.
If you taught me that, I could have beat Groome.
He said, get off that stage.
Get off that opulent mansion.
Get me out of King's house.
Characters.
He's like, you're gonna put me against the wall?
Big mistake.
Get me out of that.
That's King's mansion.
Yeah.
Let me out of there.
Oh my god, dude.
The keys to the kingdom.
Oh my god.
I've never seen that.
I don't think he's gonna play Steve again.
Yeah.
Bear time.
Dude, you got it.
all right you're on a training ground you got some walls
here all right good luck dude let's go there wait
what character is this
it's a bear
slime it's time for you to take some notes okay not these
notes though because he's getting destroyed
nice Oh, yes.
Nice job.
Nice.
Oh my god, that's her coach.
It's just, it's beautiful, the things that I see today.
I lost him on purpose so we could see this.
Was it still worth it?
Yeah.
I sandbagged on purpose.
Good shit.
Nice.
Do what he get?
Nice!
these guys are gaming there's some fucking rock paper
scissors right now he chose rock and he's winning
any rock mains any rock mains in chat rock beats everything
let's go baby
yes let's fucking go you just always throw rock exactly like
what can paper do rock can just be sharper than paper that
float was also legendary honestly oh oh my god that punish
yeah he dropped oh my god oh this is some major damage but
how long oh oh oh how long how long does he get it for there
he doesn't know mma
oh my goodness
That is the exact same way you ended it last time block in
hop kick secluded training ground punish Yeah, that's the
exact thing where you won you're welcome that I lost and
we'll get every time He dropped his combo off the doria.
He could have killed him.
Oh my god He dropped it Swapy stages does nothing.
Good fucking shit, dude.
Seriously.
Unbelievable.
Nobody does it like him.
Nobody does it.
That was sick.
Oh man, my heart is pumping.
Let's go.
But that's the thrill.
I saw you go for that cheeky exploder.
I'm like, bro, he's trying to blow him up.
He's trying to remind him the other day.
I know what you're doing.
And did you see how we worked that King's Gamma Hull against
the running bears?
thing yo he had to stop doing that move because king
absorbed it and then punched him upside the head good i was
dude yeah let's go let's go oh my god let's go so proud of
you dude so Not fucking proud of you.
Good shit.
I'm fucking shivering.
I mean, that's the highlight.
We end right there, right?
That's what I'm doing.
We watch that.
Let us out of here.
I'm there.
I can't believe it.
We farm the content.
Saiyan's happy.
I'm not happy yet.
All right, I'll bring it up the other match.
Let me see.
All right, I got a hung over.
Oh, my God.
And then we...
Locked, boxed.
Pissed it all out.
and then we play against tone fd just be you know you're on
the wave brawl pro you're on the dude everything's going to
coaches match this one is too wow it's bad this slam is so
much more scary yeah the teams are a little too close they
are oh my god everybody's just bringing it up i don't know
if it's like nerves or everything but like holy who won
against tony and uh v probably tell me i don't know oh
they're about to play right now oh they're about to play
there oh wow oh so so oh so we are streaming that so they
were just watching us were we on stream were we i fucking
hope so that dude i hope the people get to look at what what
just no it was signify versus box box on stream oh okay okay
i guess i'll restream box boxes pov oh my god this should
have been Yeah, I don't know what they were cooking.
Yeah, what were they thinking?
Yeah, how much we were fucking doing.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
I would like Tony to lose.
Actually, both of these guys have speed caves coaching them
how to beat me.
And it's annoying.
It doesn't even matter who wins.
What do they have against you?
What did you do to them?
I beat them in day one.
Dude, they're all they're talking mad shit.
They're like blood loss to Raidits.
and then everyone else lost the rateds and it's like dude oh
no no no kaiser kaiser kaiser yeah yeah yeah tony was like
yeah he was giving me shit for losing a kaiser and he gets
too owed and kaiser's like what do you say fuck me for
oh my actually the most nerve-wracking games so far i miss
round robbins i want tony to win because i want the josh
runback sure yeah and true fair enough don't did win i just
checked the ballad tone one the the coach match that's
happening right now oh yeah yeah it's a coach match tony fie
right now i'm stupid who do we want to win fie or tone i
think we want fie to win because tone's the strongest i
think it's easier yeah it's it's way easier for us if he
wins okay like like without you know respectfully cat is
tony's team is pretty like annoying like that's the esam
team i think right yeah yeah yeah tony's the esam like
literally no offense doki but esam no no 100 i agree so by
definition we want feed to win because that doesn't mean
that they get a guaranteed one win you know yeah and it's
about to happen oh my god let's go it's two two right now 10
fit combo hollywood fdx guys you guys want to watch isam is
auto one oh and then raid it's me up and like you know drag
is a huge issue for me so nice we're watching the fee match
right now chat this man oh my god fee fees downloaded to him
bounce good bounce oh that should have oh my god oh my
goodness that perfect one to zero with the cat true
that was a crazy counter hit Wait, but then if like...
Okay, but like...
That means Tone would be in loser bracket, so we might play
against Tone if Fee beats this.
Yeah, definitely.
If they lose, we could still play him again, yeah.
But we would rather fight Fee to get into Grades.
Yeah, okay.
We'd rather get that, because then we...
So right now, we're guaranteed at least third.
Yeah.
If we win again, we're guaranteed second.
Which means if we win one more set, we go to Evo,
theoretically.
No, it cancels out, dude.
Again.
If you win, then take your tickets away.
We also get home.
Oh, Amavi.
So we really want Fi to win.
Oh wow, that's a nice full combo.
Dude, Lily's broken.
Oh, what a med.
Dude, Lily is fucking insane.
I think the damage is just absurdly high on her.
That's the Evo Japan character.
yeah was fees sandbagging and turning round robins like what
where was this he just analyzed and studied oh okay i was
like where the was this this is you know just kind of a read
on my part i get the vibe fee is like very what anxious
about his like because like he's the tech and youtube guy
and if he doesn't perform he thinks people are going to care
about that like oh if you're so good why aren't you you know
what i mean like i think he takes that seriously he yeah he
hasn't learned hasn't fully embraced the skill of don't look
at comments yet right yeah it's hard it's it is hard you
know i've been really you can revel in it you know you can
get lost also sponsor curse sponsor curse true yeah he just
got sponsored too like everyone's looking yeah what do you
get sponsored by uh yeah this guy's oh he he got to 100k
within four or five months that's why it maybe hard to get
used to all the comments.
That's true.
Yeah.
It's something everyone who, like, kind of blows up has to
learn.
Unless you're already in the know.
Just turn off the monitor.
Oh, my God.
Tone's been analyzing the wrong coach.
Tone's fucking desperate, yeah.
Tone, I mean, he did a 1-2-4 there, too.
You could have dugged it.
Good shit.
One more.
Nice.
Why is it really allergic to this guy?
glowing brian oh my god oh that's gonna break before with a
generic throw
come on fie one more tony with a wall that was a jet up
right here dude he could have won no these guys have a lot
of pressure too yeah they're scared up right i'll just i'll
just remember tony's the tony's like the super top seed so
he's got all the eyes on him and he i think tony wants to
win this more than anybody like yeah he wanted me on his
team and shit like he was like hey matt you want to fucking
oh why does tony want to win so i know like i was like
hanging out in his twitch chat and he was like yo you want
to be part of my team i was like uh i mean you tried to
poach you from the from the oh my god if he was trying to
poach you should have offered money respect but like i was
like i mean it's respect for sure you're a you're a
commodity yeah you should have taken bribes you're a hot the
slams yeah sign him up oh my god heat battle heat battle oh
but left oh my god no way raiders no way oh my god that's so
close it's so close fuck man for us man yeah oh my god man
great Yo, why this slam's so close though?
Dude, every game going to coach match, bro.
This is insane.
Coach match, final finals, like, except for you, you
dominated.
Yeah, you dominated.
If it's a coach match to get first, that'd be dumb.
I would just walk off.
Y'all got it.
I'm not putting myself through that.
What?
Not for me?
For my ticket.
guys coach doesn't care random stage selection yeah that's
twt rules you can't counter pick stage it has to be random
that's insane yeah as a smash player that's yeah yeah that's
what i was gonna say because of you two but then again coney
jack eight and big guy good at the game sure yeah it's a
different way i know that's acting now buzz
now oh yeah oh my god this is so nerve-wracking i'm watching
this and i'm scared yeah i'm not slaying yeah imagine how
they look phoenix said duck that one two four tony keeps
spamming okay
nice oh he's dead no he's panicking no really damn it
they're they're making mistakes stakes now they're scared in
V lock in dude no matter how how long you've been playing
how professional you are nerves will change oh man nice
oh my God why is that hitting
oh no this might be a done deal I think he's playing so
defensively now I think when he's like kind of tilted he
reverts back to Tekken 7 style what's seven style very
defensive back dashing second it's very aggressive you have
to go in if you want to win nice counter hit fee let's go
dude voila oh oh cook this man oh that's oh that is minus 13
punish that fee okay nice power it ain't over till it's over
bring it back i cannot imagine what their team is going
through right now yeah this rock paper scissors man
no tone is winning the rock paper scissors oh my god i'm so
scared oh my god i want to close my eyes i'm closing my eyes
it's over if he didn't punish over he's in his own yeah yeah
if he didn't punish that he's gonna he's gonna tilt himself
He needs to get away from the wall.
It's over, GG.
It's over.
That's it.
Brian.
He's still stupid.
Hawkman.
Well.
Okay.
Well, time to fight Tone.
Well, all that means is that we get smoked by Tone's team
and then we fight FDX's team in Luzon's next time.
Later.
Then that will get us.
Wait a minute.
Hold on.
We could win.
We need some.
Oh, God.
We're in need of a vehicle.
He said, he said, oh, God.
Oh, God.
Brian is cheap as fuck dude at the wall oh my god oh my god
this is truly so nerve-wracking hey we got at least third
though that's big yeah that's pretty good hey I'm I told
brawl pro last night we were talking I was like as long as I
do my job like I can that's all I can focus on right all we
can focus on are our sets and obviously we want to win for
everybody but it's like All you can do is worry about your
game.
You know what I mean?
We're trying to do it as a team, so.
For real, for real.
We all got to do it together.
Yeah.
Do we get, like, an intermission going straight in?
I don't know.
I'm going to tell them, let us run to the bathroom.
Because I'm at the ghost at NYK's fight.
But I wanted to watch that set.
A lot of pisses pants.
Oh.
Oh, they are going to the losers right now on the
mainstream.
though oh so we're most likely we might have to join the
lobby soon yeah oh
i don't even play techin i'm just as nervous
oh damn i'm freaking it
all right i will be right back fellas
oh my god that was so nervous i think like i think i i
definitely like against goomy i definitely hesitated so much
because i started thinking too much i think it's because
like uh uh i was i was like i was just thinking too much in
that last game and then yeah i got in my own head
I got into my own head and I fucked up, yeah I kept thinking
about block block block So then I forgot how to be
aggressive Because like that's how like I won like rounds
When I was more aggressive But oh my god I was like I was
too nervous there Yeah I just gotta relax My hands, my
fingers during the round robins I was not, my fingers never
shook I was so like, I was technically like like relaxed
enjoying the rand robins but this is like the like the first
time i my hands actually were shaking i was actually shaking
and i was like yeah the pressure got to me but like um it
was still close it was so close i just ended up like not
punishing or doing damage i got defense i defended but i
didn't do anything after defending but maybe i purposely
lost so we can get that sick ass brawl pro match i don't
know if i if i won we wouldn't have saw the match we saw
today i'm just saying guys i'm just saying we wouldn't have
been able to see some sick ass techin we did it the the wall
jumps and everything come on we wouldn't have that content
guys it was fate yeah i i sandbagged so we could see that
sick ass chicken
that wall jump was fucking sick come on guys if i won we
didn't see that it was for the the content.
Focus on trying to win.
Okay, guys, we're not winning against ESAM.
I'm, like, the resident punching bag.
I'm the punching bag for the team.
Like, we're not.
Bro, ESAM's a fucking...
Who the fuck let this fucking Super Smash Bros.
play fourth seed?
Like, who the fuck allowed this to happen?
This person is a Smash Bros.
pro player.
It's just Smash.
Just think it's right.
Oh, do the cheesy stuff I do in ring.
Bro, I hate playing it.
We lose matches first before our match.
I thought they...
So, we got a little bit more.
So, yeah, yeah.
break oh there you go i'll pretend this is bro this is this
is esam right here oh my god perfect esam he doesn't slide
it's not him he doesn't slide he needs to slide the moment
he starts sliding then it's esam because esam fucking abuses
that crazy goodbye boom oh shit he actually he actually no
isam please isam okay leave me alone
okay if he abuse it he's predictable but he knows that's the
thing He knows if I start blocking he fucking He swaps these
he actually adapts Because he comes from fighting games and
they actually adapt.
I don't adapt That's the thing.
I'll be like what you mean I have to change my moveset?
What what do you mean I have to change how I play?
I lose that I can block see I blocked but what does blocking
do for me look at that I blocked and I started getting shit
on guys who told me to block
look I blocked see I blocked there you go why the How the
fuck did you do that?
Why?
I was low!
Oh my god.
Get away from me!
Go back to Smash Brothers!
Go back!
You're fucking bald!
Yay.
Alright, back.
Sorry about that.
Welcome back.
We gotta play against laws Not really Hey, I'm watching
stream round one.
I'm watching this.
I see you beat ESAM Yo, oh wait, he's purple wrecked just
like him Just like ESAM!
He's purple too Oh my god He's just like him Box box was
seven feet tall until yesterday.
That man is real by the way good shit in that set guys Yeah,
no matter what we're fucking top three.
Oh god.
We're in the money.
If this was a normal tournament I mean you just have to win
one more set whether it's winners or losers in the top two.
This happened to us in the first three.
So Yeah, we can do it bro Okay, here we go My biggest issue
with tournaments is like I know we can win like I know I can
beat anybody I know you guys can beat anybody, but will we
right there we go.
Yeah, that's that's the scary part like who's better today
Boom, boom, oh Yeah, I'm the head That's fucking right Isam
Go back to your original game Okay.
At least my company likes the game I play.
Wait, that's fucked up.
At least the game company likes it when I play their video
game.
You know it's true.
Apex never shut down anything.
That's like, that's why you have to use Tekken as a crutch!
I don't know, Isam, I don't know who you are.
It's just Tekken.
Oh, true.
They're talking about anti-Matman strats on Boxstream.
Why?
Okay, rematch.
He's not, he's not, he's just said he has it.
It's so funny that they're trying so hard to like...
prep for you specifically like why man i'm just trying to
play games because you are the nuclear weapon you are the oh
my god please i don't i don't adapt i'm sorry i don't just
send in the fucking weapon man i don't adapt they definitely
this might be the time where they've literally had enough
slams and enough time where they've labbed enough it gets
specifically like me style we'll see but you adapted a star
did though but you adapted with the gamma how that was the
biggest fuck you i've ever seen no i gotta watch i gotta
watch that back do this it's funny to see different styles
because like i kind of run over zintrea because i just put
on pressure but james is like slower which is better against
raided but worse against zintrea because he gives her more
opportunities to like get away from you yeah everyone's got
their own style it can work yeah yeah boom zentrea's up one
though yeah that was ugly cancans though she's popping too
much oh no you're not supposed to grab you just do kicks ah
that's all okay i did not think you would i thought you were
gonna duck please take me back to the other side please i
don't that's nasty man you should you should do it he does
the hop kick at the wall into the choke that's that's drop
kick i'm angry i'm fucking mad i don't know what else to do
with the wall i mean i'm doing the three kicks but maybe i
can't oh what no
let me leave let me get up what the fuck okay this is how
it's gonna go with me and esaf the future definitely it
shows the way he plays like traditional fighters you know
what i mean we saw the future yeah
just guessing right a lot well it's just block and then
maybe this if he starts sliding i just do this but like it's
so the timing is a lot his rage clip he never wants that to
happen again that's why he's just trying to stop that
forever yeah yeah so he plays very proper now if you take
one set from east to him he has to unplug i did as like uh
we talked about it yesterday the wizard is interesting i
didn't even think of oh my god he's doing that a lot fight
he counter hitter in her rage drive i think that was crazy i
don't know for some reason i thought it would work again i
was like that'd be funny if it works you know
i just thought it'd be funny if it worked again this one
might be done might be the end of kfm actually no they're
they're up one oh this should just make it one one
Okay, again.
This shit's stressful.
Stressful as fuck, dude.
I'd rather fight the rogue game than close to it.
Punish, though.
Good hop.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh, I don't get this.
Please.
Oh.
Sorry.
No.
This scream that stress away.
Ah!
I have to fight!
Isa!
Whoa, what the hell?
So you can duck that one.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, that dropped probably.
It bounced.
Wow, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, she's clutching it out.
Oh my god.
Bro, I watched some of her sets back.
What's the point of looking?
I can just smash!
Oh, fuck, he dropped.
She was toxic.
She was saying some shit, dude.
What?
She was being toxic.
She was like, get that spammer out of the fucking lobby,
spamming fucking cringe.
I was like, Jesus.
Like, oh my God.
Oh my God.
It was crazy.
That's just like you after you beat me, Rob.
I'm fucking better than you.
Well, I was better than you.
This is it.
Fuck this.
Fuck doing actual combos.
I was better though.
This is the way to go.
I was so annoyed, bro.
I was so annoyed.
He was just doing the same fuck.
I hate losing the bots, bro.
I can't do it.
but she did she came back around after a second she was like
i was you know it was just like a release of tension but one
more this is fuck this i don't need combos to sound like i
think i think james gets nervous bro like bro i don't know
who cares about combos why am i trying new things do what
you do what you what you did to get to this elo when the
alley kick He's pressure now.
Oh, yeah.
More pressure.
Doki it.
You fucking listen to people trying to block and everything
and do what got you into this Elo.
Do what's right.
Do fucking do what's fucking right.
Don't let them tell you what to do.
Just do what's fucking right.
If she finished that combo.
Oh, I'm behind.
Oh, she dropped it.
Do what comes naturally.
Yoki, you thought too much against Gumi.
You thought too much.
You were thinking.
And then you get it.
All you did was block.
You fucking, you were, you were not, you were known as 30
defense, Doki.
Not, it was not meant to be.
The moment I started attacking it was over.
He's not blocking me.
I was like, you're right.
I asked to get a twirl.
How's this?
My ass is getting twirled.
Oh my god.
He wishes he was mad.
You need a punish here!
Zen!
Oh my god, dude.
There's no way.
He wishes he was just like him!
There's no way, dude.
You're not like Jack Jesus!
You're cooking this man.
You're so fucking bad!
alley kicked i'm watching it from zen like i'm watching no
one needs defense and her team is defense is by losers you
got to win with my different defending
get off no one needs defense yeah i don't i didn't know zen
got this good this quickly she's in car you dude bro oh yeah
okay he's starting to do i guess they haven't been playing
rank guys been practicing yeah guys damn james cook wow
final game final round no bro why are you defending there he
just can't he goes for burning knuckle james is like
disrespectful okay he's an animal dude he did that leave me
alone leave me alone no way he's spamming he's oh my My god!
Bam!
Fuck off!
That's fucking right.
He's such a nerd.
Freakin' James Chensor.
Elbow, elbow, elbow, elbow, elbow, elbow, elbow.
No, no, he broke my wall.
My floor!
That was mad close.
He broke my floor!
You see the chat?
My floor!
In the Discord chat!
Wait, what?
Look at stage one.
Block it.
is cringe.
Attacks are the only weakness.
I see it, dude.
See, it's no blocking is fucking stupid.
Blocking is so fucking stupid.
I mean, those two elbows look like a good combo to me.
Blocking is so stupid.
A little bit of 1-2 action.
Still not Jack, Jesus.
Jack would have fucking...
not have would not have given me a round i'm just i just
wanted that's all i'm saying matt would not have given me
that round oh no oh adaption it's spamming oh no no oh my
god what did that kick bro jack jesus exactly not my jack
jesus Jack Jesus would have swept me so hard.
The Keck doesn't, like, move.
Hold on.
Let me see if I can...
There it goes.
But then...
Oh, my God.
Fighting games are funny, bro.
All right.
It's a good time.
It's, like, super stressful.
After this game, we're going to live watch with the homies.
The False Prophet.
Yeah, Matt would have gone four perfects out of this.
yeah if this was matt he wouldn't have let me stood up what
is wrong with you and you trying to learn jack if you can't
get three perfects in a row uninstall now roy shiato man he
should be the first scene oh my god dude fairlight is also i
knew i knew i knew but locking was never it but that guy is
he spams a lot of shoulder and he gets away with it uh in
his in his tier we gotta launch that like if he did it on
slime once like slime kills him like more like 80 if he has
heat and a wall oh roy beat fairlight apparently okay yes
you don't learn all the moves just learn like the moves you
can take it in feels like he's supposed to be like the shoto
right he's like the most basic character but he's got these
weird fucking corny like it doesn't feel like I'm losing to
a Shoto you know what I mean like it's hard to explain that
oh yeah he's like the weirdest Shoto I've ever seen in a
funny show no don't you wait trying to do blocking again
have you not learned
anything she must are really not comparable I just mean like
as like the default characters oh my god don't you look what
happened What happened to you?
Oh!
Guys, I need to stop blocking.
It's a good ending.
I need to stop blocking, guys.
It's actually messing me up.
It's a good timeline.
It all worked out.
It's all, it actually is messing me up.
Stop learning blocking!
He knows what's in it.
Oh, shit.
I punched the wrong thing.
Tekken is weird because the poster boys in the heart.
character oh that's a good point yeah because the three
fighters like ken for you okay there you are kind of not
easy but like you know there you go is probably the most
demanding he's been the poster boy forever and now it's jinn
he's easier okay there you go oh my god oh my god let me
punch you let me punch you let me punch you maybe victor is
there like a legacy like this character
so low Paul has a high skill ceiling but I feel like new
players can pick him up though but I feel like that's really
good design when new players can pick him up but the ceiling
is still very high right they could stick I'm gonna step you
on the crouch oh I'm sorry I gotta thank King I don't
disagree bro King is not oh please good to pick up do my
thing in this game he's not the easiest to optimize though
you got to land all the your blue sparks nice okay right
stuff like you got to that i didn't mean to do that i didn't
mean at least let me get up at least let me get up bro can't
get carried away with the grabs because one grab is ducked
you lose half your life okay but what if i do that i
genuinely oh that's how you guys played so many grabs like
my brain can't like what it was doing to you like how does
your brain work that fast it's crazy it's just the pace of
the game really okay part of what makes it how was i too
slow for this look at the hands you look at the hand and you
can also that's crazy well you can judge the situation also
because giant swing comes out faster than the others so my
case that's right i punch you oh i don't punch you press the
wrong one so leave me alone and also habits oh what king
players like to go what grab they like to go for at what
distance i guess like if the wall i buffered it i buffer oh
i didn't buffer it because i'm go i'm not gaming anymore
I mean, I know that people have set up like, um, what a
block, people set up like training regiments for hand stuff.
And I feel like if you do that for like, you know, six
hours.
Maybe it'll be like, yeah, if you do it 15 minutes a day for
a week, I don't see you not getting tired of that.
Oh my god, how does he fucking just jab?
Such an easy tech to get used to.
Our reaction time is...
Okay, nice.
I got that.
I actually died.
Intentionally!
slime is doing it yesterday the day we were oh what the fuck
he just grabbed me that should be illegal oh no oh dude yeah
don't turn that it was funny but blocking is for fucking
pussies okay let's watch let's watch the match with
everybody all right let me grab the stream cool okay where
is the stream wow did my chat so much better now say jam
twitch all right here you go pin message
are they tied right now I'm watching it now look at the
bottom the check marks at the bottom they'll tell you oh
it's one to one yep yeah yeah this shit's close everything's
going final game it's unbelievable which is crazy dude who
do we want to win Roy Chiado is a nerd so the other team oh
okay well I think they brought us close the only person we
didn't on Roy's team didn't we only lose to Roy no I lost to
Logan Logan like Logan beat me once and then I lost to Logan
on the second because they he hard studied uh king yeah so
she beat him first time he beat her second time I'll beat
Zentrea probably I mean I assume um you know Roy's very good
I forget who the fourth seed on KFM's team is um uh did we
beat him yeah I know that's the guy yeah oh yeah he beat oh
yeah yeah he was the one that beat him yeah
actively play against hey best case scenario we fight scar's
team sure so we want nyk to win i don't want to fight james
chen again man yeah but like i i'm too low bro for the one
time you guys gotta carry my ass but looking hard studied
We got it.
We'll lock in I mean this isn't losers.
This is assuming we lose to Tony.
We could just win beat Tony in that That's funny.
I was just in replay system studying the fuck out of box box
It's their fucking fourth.
It's fucking ESAM dude.
It's so annoying.
What is he doing there?
Okay, if I take like one round off of him, I should just win
I know you should just tell him that I should just win.
That's not fair I told Seijam that after the whole thing is
done, I want to do an exhibition Tekken Ball.
An exhibition Tekken Ball?
I don't know who wants to Tekken Ball me, but someone's
going to get bald on.
Kaiser and Fear also won one.
That's crazy, dude.
Wait, who are we playing against if we lose to Tone?
I don't know if we know yet.
We don't know.
this bracket has to play a different person right i think so
i've honestly forgotten loser this gets uh fifth and are out
oh okay so then yeah it's gonna be them versus whoever
whoever wins the other loser bracket right and then we fight
then we fight then who's in the okay so out of all four
teams that hit the wall geez right i don't even know who is
in the losers right now i mean obviously fee if it's fee
guys on fee kaiser and then miles and yk right oh amaz is
like fucking destroying scar right now he's destroying this
man yeah alissa is a crack character like if when matt loses
to amaz that's supposed to be a 60 40 i think for jack but
that's why it hurts more when you lose and you got the
favorable matchup bit just a little bit yeah but i just
didn't know the matchup last time i've gone and studied oh
yeah brock pro actually coached him this time i saw it with
my own hands still lose i saw it at six four doki was there
she heard it yeah i'm the i'm the witness why is scar
getting hit by that hop kick like that because no one knows
alissa bro what the kind of character has a double hitting
hop kick why is she always in the air rip her wings out like
that shit happened to no one's played Tekken 7 before in
their life let's be real here everyone who's played Tekken 7
is old as fuck in your chat whoa who played Tekken 7
actually I played Tekken 7 oh okay so you're old as fuck I
played it for this is 100 hours this has got to hurt like
being the guy that like like if Scar loses this like the
code doesn't knock you out of the tournament you're out of
the you know what I mean yeah that's not a suck oh my god
that's oh I am telling you that team is fucking godlike no
yeah but then they still have to fight the other the other
two or like the other what team yeah I think I can think of
Oz now I know you can take him I should have lost this one
but yeah you can absolutely win he'll be a scar situation
where he fucks on me you know oh remember at the wall he
loves That down 4, 1 plus 2.
Scar doesn't know how to punish.
That sucks for him.
Wait, so how do I block the slide from Law again?
You just block.
When he's mid-range and crouching from mid-range, he's
probably going to do it.
Then you just down back.
Down back.
Okay.
Yeah, you block low and then you mash 4, just like Yoshi.
And then he'll go in the air and then you can decide what to
do after.
It's not enough time to tell you.
But technically, that's supposed to lead into a con.
If you block slide, it's supposed to be a combo.
When you block it, it's spam alley kick.
If you want.
There you go.
Yeah, yeah.
Spam alley kick.
Okay.
All I do is just spam alley kicks.
Yeah.
Block it.
When you block it, it's coming.
Block it if you think it's coming.
And then afterwards, spam the fuck out of alley kick.
Oh, he might win from this.
Dude, look how many times he does the fucking float low.
I'm telling you, man.
Yeah.
The most flow chart, Alyssa, I've ever seen in my life.
i wonder if they talk dude i'm sure they did because like
you and i were talking last night you know like i fucking
you know how i feel dude all this fucking jack does is spam
grabs like you know this i know they've said all i do is
spam grabs too at some point we're playing king you're king
we are talking mad shit i know everybody does
least like at least apex supports tournaments oh my god the
image dude victor oh the one one needs to be ducked look at
that gray life oh oh my god oh scott ride doesn't know he
blocked oh my goodness okay wait wait a minute wait a minute
signs of wait a minute signs of eight hours dream he's
waking up he's waking up
Almost.
Those are four highs in a row.
That's minus 14.
That low mid.
That's like minus 30.
I went in the replay system.
Oh my god.
Goodbye, Skara.
Oh, good.
But it's over.
At least he knows how I felt.
It's over.
He knows how I felt.
Goodbye.
This is the first team where it's not a coach match, right?
Yeah, yeah.
They were able to 3-0.
To be fair, they had to play against Roy.
Roy Chata, which is a free win for them.
Yeah.
It feels like a lot of the tiers have a free win in their
tier.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like they got the first seed.
Roy Chata, they got the third seed.
You guys got me.
Not eco, but you know, let's be real.
talk your shit let's be real
all right and we're playing next right no i think it's them
the person who just won kawaii face miles versus whoever won
fidex oh so there so it was two loser brackets and then us i
don't know is it oh they're going all the way up okay oh
okay is this a bracket yeah yeah okay so kfm just won fidex
versus kaiser is gonna happen and then we're fighting them
okay or or not we have to wait for all the same time both
losers brackets but we're playing at the same time I'm just
fucking stupid they're playing we're gonna fight Tone's
right we're fighting Tone's team after that we'll fight
whoever wins this assuming we lose assuming we lose which we
shouldn't yeah because Komi's gonna clutch it for us I might
I mean I might true FD signifier versus Monkey the animal.
Oh, Eddie, moment.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Well, we can all tap on this one.
Okay.
We have that.
Here, the bracket, I guess I can post it in our chat.
Okay.
There you go.
What's the score on the other loser bracket?
Does anyone know what the score is on the other loser
bracket?
Or is it in the...
Oh, it's in the challenge.
Okay.
Yeah, the Chalong.
Chalong.
I didn't know people used Chalong still.
They didn't even update it.
Womp, womp.
I don't know who's winning.
Chat, who's winning right now?
I don't know.
They don't have the overlay.
Fierke Kaiser.
Don't worry, my chat will stream tonight for me.
Oh, they pulled up the overlay.
Oh, nice.
Oh, wait, it's the wrong one.
Oh, wow.
like your ft6 is on uh eddie not zaff yeah but he was he was
zaff against boxbox i think it's just literally he is
winning apparently dude you know about the 333 yeah not
really what the fuck do you mean what the fuck do you mean
we never went over it bro but you've watched the threat that
three guy no i did not i i watched him for like five seconds
i was like well and then i bro that's no it is not look at
him go he's fucking going nasty with it is he really no he's
not spamming threes anymore oh god
he's so fly isn't it like there's a fucking high somewhere
or some shit
no punish this guy just doesn't know the matchup worst in
peace shifter
we're currently just watching the uh a jam stream because
we're not playing yet uh we're not playing yet so we're just
watching uh who who's gonna win up this matchup what a copy
pasta to be fair you have to have very high iq to press 3s
3d the timing is extremely subtle and with a solid grasp of
frame data most of the kicks will whiff there's also three
he's optimistic outlook which is definitely woven into his
kicks his personal philosophy draws heavily from Jose
literature, for instance, the fans understand this stuff,
the intellectual capacity to truly appreciate the difficulty
of hitting the combo to realize that it's not just hard.
Okay, that's good.
Whoever wrote that.
All right, sorry, I just had to go watch a clip of MYK going
off on me.
It was funny.
It's not, I feel so bad for MYK.
Getting third in the last one, one going fighting you again
losing again like fuck man guys you just don't understand
hey it's on scar it's not even on me scar let him down yeah
drew he's a very difficult character you guys are just
jealous well they made new fan art for us that one's pretty
cool too damn these guys are crazy don't retweeted yeah
there's another one I have to find it there's new fan art
Yeah, yeah, this one's really cool too.
Oh, I retweeted already.
Oh, the one where we were wearing the Jaguar hats Yeah, if I
if I have more time.
Yeah, that one of those numb have you guys seen that like
LeBron James scream if you love I want to do that scream if
you love team brawl pro when he points up That's the Jack
Jesus throw.
You know what I mean?
When he punches his teammate those are the alley kicks just
like I wanted to make it, but I didn't have time
I'm not going my way to do it.
I'm not uploading tomorrow because this is too much stress.
So I might.
You're taking your first day off in two years.
Oh my god.
Your first day off in two years, dude.
All it took was Tekken 8.
I took a day off the first lamp too, like afterwards.
Oh my god, dude.
One.
Oh, it's a...
Why did they just tune into him getting smoked?
Yeah.
Right.
Oh, Matt, if you do make it, the Scream for Scream if you
love Team Bro Pro is Doki.
Is it?
Yay!
That's the one.
That's my shit, bro.
Oh, we've been added.
It's time to play.
It's time?
But what about the other loser bracket?
Let's fucking get it.
Oh!
Okay, we gotta wait for the lobby.
Alright, guys.
It's almost time.
Guys, today I'm going to...
will super be featured in the brawl pro edit we could do
something about cutting him cutting super i don't know he
was trying to help the ops he was helping just like no
really i told him he's uninvited to the evo party that's
insane no during his moments just like like crop my picture
and put it on like put it on his face yeah just everywhere
you go yeah that's insane dude this fuck that that's crazy
yeah we saw him there's vods he was training sk
i was like how dare you but then it didn't actually end up
mattering you know because you know that sk might come in
and fight us if we lose the tone oh yeah if we lose the tone
and they win all right he's uninvited because yeah if he and
kfm are fighting so if few wins that i have to fight sk what
is exclamation mark snack do i get one is that the snack box
i don't know i can't i mean i got one for free oh yeah i
don't even know the prizes for this one honestly other than
the top two i don't like what do we get for third a
controller i think a controller i'm pretty sure guys
i'm ready to get my ass kicked guys I'm ready to be shown
that I'm ready I'm ready to fucking be on the floor Try to
get one round goal guys our goal today is to get one round
off of off of e7 That's that's the dream right there I
Wait, can I get that?
Wait, what do you text?
Alright.
Oh, they're texting something for a prize.
We're just waiting for a lobby right now.
Chat.
I only kick ease.
If I can get to him.
It's already.
Like, if I can fucking reach him.
Okay.
he's so fucking fast i don't even know if i can reach him in
time don't think feel true true that was my issue i kept
thinking like when i don't think i win every game it's
actually crazy i just need to fucking stop
i need like no no thoughts head empty that's how i win my
game I literally how I won
No brain Only grab true True I just need to do that
Oh There's the lobby code Alright guys I will hide my screen
Because they They're doing that thing where there's a
password So you can't complain that I leaked Um
Okay, it's 5-4-3-4, guys.
If you want to join the lobby, that is the code.
So true.
I'm in.
I'm ready to get destroyed.
Kony just showed it.
Oh, my God.
If Kony just showed it, what's the point?
Okay.
What's the point?
He already showed it!
What the fuck is the point?
Thanks, Kony.
Alright.
Oh!
Ah!
Is everybody in?
Two, four, two, three.
Oh, wait.
We don't even have, like, majority of players in here.
Ah, ah.
Wait, that's not 543.
They changed it, guys.
They changed the passcode last minute.
It was 5434 when I was putting the password in, guys.
They just changed it last second, chat.
You just didn't see it because my screen was hidden.
It was such a fast passcode.
would change.
Because they're like, oh my god, Kony leaked the password.
So then they changed it, guys.
They changed it before we could, you know, before I could
tell you guys the new password.
I would never.
How dare you guys think I would lie?
Doki would never do that to you.
Doki is the way of life.
The first commandment in the Doki lore is that shall not lie
and by that i mean you guys shouldn't lie to me all right
here we go again let's get it fellows here we go they say
don't start oh oh okay it's okay guys i'm like the appetizer
before the main meal
Let's go.
Let's get Kony can watch me and just be like, okay, I should
not do that.
No, I'll be inspired.
More kicks, more kicks, more kicks.
Lots of kicks.
Now I beat James Chen, the Chen Destroyer, true.
Oh my gosh, wait.
You're right, our coach is in the interview.
He's not here to give us tips.
He's too busy in an interview.
Oh my god.
Wait, what the fuck?
This guy's labbing against me.
Hold on.
Get this guy.
Oh my god.
Can't believe it.
The coaches aren't even here to coach us.
What do I do?
Stop hitting a joint.
Never.
I'm gonna join forever.
It's not my fault.
I can't believe it.
They're doing an interview?
Stop!
It's not- I'm more important.
So how was the labbing going?
You like pulled up the replays I fought against him
yesterday.
You should pull up the replays too.
I did before he did, I'm actually...
Yeah!
Alright.
Does anyone know where Isam lives?
Can someone pull his plug?
Florida.
Don't talk, Isam.
This is a joke for legal reasons.
It's widely known.
Oh, okay.
For legal reasons, please don't go to Isam's place.
I just knew the right answer, so I want a teacher to pick
me.
That's okay.
But if suddenly there is a power outage in wherever Isam
lives in the district that he lives, we were not part of the
problem.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on.
Are you still in the interview?
I guess they are.
For legal reasons, that was a joke.
And all I said was a power outage.
If God suddenly sent a power outage to florida then him
losing was meant to be
it was just meant to be true
jack jesus hear my prayers
have a rat chew the power cables hear my my prayers Jack
Jesus send that rat in amen
all right sorry they pulled me in for an interview that's
why I was gone what did you say about us good things right
uh they didn't ask me anything about in they just asked us
what they pulled you into interview and didn't even ask
about us
the kind of james bald james bald we talked about that by
the way just so you know we talked about like yeah for two
minutes you should oh the truth they can't censor us all
right guys let's see if i can pull that round off of this
man let's go he went to last game last round against SK yeah
but I feel like SK actually fucking trained oh my god I
forgot everything you taught me about ducking mid range guys
I forgot everything I forgot everything that's okay no
thoughts that's how it always works until today wow he
really wants to go to evil this guy really wants to go.
This guy really wants to go.
Okay, good try, good try.
You guys will deny it for me, right?
Yeah, of course.
Oh my god.
He's doing the down two, three, oh my god.
What does that mean?
Nothing.
Don't listen to me.
He's very good.
It means he's very good.
Oh, that makes sense.
I could feel it right now.
It definitely... No, he's doing that thing!
Oh my god, please don't slide.
He is the online law player.
We found him.
He's real.
Oh my god.
Isam fights like you owe him hair.
That's pretty good.
Oh, back three!
Back three!
Here we go!
Boom!
Just down the kick, you get hit.
I did it!
It's over.
You got one!
Alright, it's over.
End this game now.
I won the round.
Oh, just to leave.
Just to leave.
Oh no, he's doing that now.
That's fucking right!
Fucking nerd.
Fucking nerd!
You slide!
Nobody likes it!
Get his ass!
Leave!
Oh, shut up!
Nobody!
Oh, shit!
Oh, no, he's doing that thing.
Oh, good dog.
Oh, I like the idea.
Thank you.
I'm glad you do.
Oh, shit.
Hey, I'm back on the side!
That's clean!
That's a clean fucking...
That's...
He's not dead.
dead nice we need one more mix you got it wait oh you got it
you got it you can do this you can do this dokey oh god a
fluke are you sure i'm sure i'm sure it does to be back to
the other side no he knows oh he took me back to the side
thank god okay let's fucking go good oh no but let's go me
guys i think he analyzed the situation oh my god doesn't
matter you played i took two rounds when he does you can
block that right if you hold back yeah does the slide no
it's guaranteed oh is it all right never mind yeah guys it's
just donkey honestly you played that extremely well oh my
god honestly it's embarrassing for him because he didn't get
a perfect
You win.
Like, yeah, like, kind of well...
I'm serious.
I'm gonna do that then.
Because that's all he's doing.
Like, King.
All I'm saying is it's very embarrassing that he let me win
two rounds.
Doki, remember we talked about you can low parry that slide
too?
We talked about that?
I mean, you can do that.
The down forward square?
No, no, just down forward is the low parry.
Oh, down forward, okay.
Down forward.
Down forward, not down forward.
I don't want to confuse.
Just hold down and you'll block it.
Yeah.
Just hold down, you'll block it.
You almost beat him when he got so much free damage off
that.
It was basically a free round.
Of course.
Dude, it's Pikachu.
Oh, my God, it is!
Mob kiss.
Oh, my God.
That's fine.
That's still damage.
His teeth?
That's fine, too.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, he's actually adapting.
What is wrong with him?
A lot of things.
No, this guy's fucking weird.
Who the fuck adapts in the fighting game?
What are we doing?
I know!
Oh, nice throw.
Does he duck?
Oh, he does duck now.
Duck Lord.
Chew.
Yawn.
I'm scared.
Yeah, you should be.
Losing two rounds to a B2B?
Boom!
Go back to Smash Bros.
Oh shit.
I need to remember that he does.
Oh, he missed it.
okay okay oh no I wanted to rage out oh oh she he hits me
first yeah let's try it's a good shot yeah yeah oh oh yeah
oh he ducked it nice oh my god oh I'm a dragon what is that
what is that move I've never seen it before in my life oh he
gets that off if dss was still hard to do this man will be
cooked right now
oh i mean like the fact that you even made him sweat i i
felt it from his monitor yeah right you went last round last
round i've got the aura change you know what it's just
embarrassing that he lost the two rounds there he had to he
had to change his stride not that much better Oh, it's
better.
Unironically, yeah.
I accidentally left the session.
Give me a sec.
Remember, Kony, if he ever does the spinny low on you, mash
four.
Right.
Yep.
Also, like, if you think he's going to do it, it's hop
kickable, you know.
Yep.
And back four to one is a high.
The third hit is a high, right, Kony?
A duck and a hop kick up.
But I'm going to have to wait.
This last time I got fucked up because I got countered.
And we watched how...
chen sore beat him he did like he did like big jabs and like
a down back three and he did shit like that yeah dick jab
him hella he'll win oh i didn't mean to pick this skin hold
on oh hold on i mean i don't think you know it's probably
better yeah you can uh go back to the menu after no it's
cool play it guys it doesn't matter the other team leaked it
already all the other teams leaked the code one red soupa
for every round you take off east Thank you for the alcohol.
I'm gonna play the fuck out of Pikmin.
Thank you.
He should be embarrassed.
He literally, I was looking at the Discord.
He was in the Seijam Slam Discord from morning to night
yesterday.
Fucking practicing.
It was actually crazy.
I was literally watching, like, I was looking at the server
and like, he was there just Tekken.
Okay.
Oh, there you go.
He went for the fucking stupid move.
You got that shit.
That's counter hit.
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
Let's go, Cody!
Nice.
Nice job.
Let's go.
Break his streak.
Oh, my God.
He's a dunker.
Oh, what a matter of hit, Cody.
Yeah, get the fuck up.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Hold back to get up.
Nice.
Wake up.
I'm, like, five seconds behind.
Yeah, I'm pretty behind, too.
Nice.
Obviously, we left there.
Like, obviously, you got that.
We can only think about what's happening.
Yeah.
If I close my eyes, I can see it.
Just close your eyes and think about it.
oh
oh what a hockey i saw it it was cool it was dope oh my god
if only could see that live yeah when he does that low that
fucking low yeah i know yes yes yes right oh
every fucking time man back to get up that's free in here
yeah fuck that's okay that's okay that's okay know what the
fuck he's doing way way closer yeah definitely you
definitely have to play him a few times to get used to yeah
yeah just like even on hit on block just match for once you
see the right yeah he's not I'm not thinking I'm not
thinking Thinking fast enough.
I remember, Kony, after that grab, if he grabs you, just
hold back to get up.
Those kicks won't hit you.
You got it.
Nice.
I mean, like, what a fucking move.
Andy doesn't have to get up right.
Andy just fucking duck.
Agent Kony Banks.
Oh, cool.
Nice.
Got me.
What a hop kick!
Oh my fucking goodness.
That's the real counterplay to that.
Let's go.
Let's go, Kony!
Get my revenge!
Nice.
He's ducking hella.
Yeah, that wall.
Nice.
Does he get up correctly from shoulder?
He does not.
Where's that next?
Oh my God, you're just gonna be crazy.
You're insane.
Fight.
All right.
R1 start.
Nice.
That's such a good combo.
Coach, why didn't you teach me that combo?
I tried to.
You have trouble with it.
You can try hiding.
Oh my God, he's got a lot of giants.
Oh my God.
He can't do the wall.
let's go oh my god it's just a red pickman he's not even a
flower pickman yeah
after you're running three coney you can hop kick this guy
and also he's not ducking so you can do shining wizards now
because right right right yeah but again if you hit him with
a running three from long range he's gonna do down two every
time well that's what he's doing yeah yeah literally the
only time he didn't do it was that final final hit every
time you've hit plus frames he does down too my read is plus
frames hop kick but you know up to you of course get ready
for the next battle stone coney steve austin oh my god look
at him go
one hook this i mean just fucking it's as simple as that
really that's up to you to make the adjustment
clean oh okay okay okay yeah okay that means that he's
willing to rage art another time just keep that yes yeah
that means that he will kill himself later get
rage art here right fuck yeah I forgot yeah as soon as you
said that was like shit I know I know what I said wouldn't
have worked actually let's go baby my power crush
let's go cody come on cody
yes look at him yes oh my god nice jump kick force that 50
50 in the corner look he's literally back to the corner what
can he do yes oh look at him look at him fucking yes for
your life Stop fucking running.
Oh my goodness.
I saw it now.
Yeah, baby.
Nice.
Oh, he's mad.
Oh, you are unreal.
You are unreal.
That was insane.
Round four.
I couldn't.
Oh my god.
Guys, this is This is a real king player.
Oh.
That's okay.
It's all right.
Yeah.
My read is next time you're even a little bit enraged.
Just mash it.
Fuck it, send it, dude.
Oh, I can't watch.
I'm so scared.
I'm closing my eyes.
Oh my god, the giant swing is incredible.
That's fine.
Burned it easy.
There's no way.
My god!
Did he do it?
Yeah!
They did it!
Barts!
Bouts!
Oh my game!
Ranking dragon off, bot!
It's one of the fucking string!
Over and over!
Get the fuck out of here!
Raid, it's the frog?
Level 9 computer bullshit!
Roger the dragon alone?
Yeah!
Arcade mode, last fight before Heihachi, bullshit!
I am better!
Oh yeah.
Oh my fucking god, dude.
Oh my goodness, gracious.
holy shit man that was frustrating speak your truth coney
like yell it to the world dude you are the goat for the
adaptation man holy i mean i've never seen something more
beautiful in my life it's so hot dude the last set that i
lost was because that thing that you told me where i was
getting counter hit if i just didn't get counter hit yes i
lost so much shit off that because i was trying too hard to
implement it fuck man here we go you're actually crazy
Okay.
Namaste.
Let's fucking go, brother.
You brought a beer.
Oh my god.
Let's fucking get it.
Go, slime.
Go.
We believe in you.
How hard, how, how fast is your heart beating right now?
It's so frustrating.
I feel like you need it.
Dragon all this is so frustrating, bro.
I feel like you need a fucking drink after that.
Oh, I can't spectate.
All right, let's get it, Slon.
I'm going to restream Kony.
It's not letting me in the lobby.
Oh my god, no, it's Brian.
He's a dick punch man, right?
Uh, no.
He's the guy that goes dick, dick, dick, dick, dick.
Yeah, he's a dick punch man!
And he sometimes goes cock.
Oh, yeah.
Good shit.
Okay.
We wait for that.
We break it.
I'm sure there's another move.
It's all good.
We're still up.
Radar happens.
That's just knowledge.
Slime recognize the wall splats.
You could have won after your back one wall splats.
Okay.
If the wall is on that side and you're back one, just think
about it.
Very close.
Wow, what a block.
That was a crazy block.
Send the rage guard when he's about to win.
He's pressuring like that.
It will work.
Nice.
Nice!
Eat him!
Big dude!
Nice slime.
What was the orbital fucking hit me there?
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
It's fine.
We have another set.
He does let the fucking rage art rip, and I think you should
rip it too.
You gotta set the tone.
Oh!
Insane!
That's crazy I apologize.
Yeah, that was a whiff punish.
Oh.
Round two.
Fight.
Oh.
good shit nice damn that does a lot oh my god that was such
a good combo fuck me
nice good shit good punish
nice should have done an easier low hell sweep was really
dumb there he just reacted I don't know why hell sweeps.
It's all good.
Let it go.
It's okay.
Nice try.
Nice try, dude.
All right.
I'm going to try a bit.
Honestly, last night, Boxbox beat the fuck out of me, so.
Use what he got you with, though.
Use what he got you with.
Yeah.
You got it this time, dude.
He showed his cards, so now you know exactly his moves.
Until he starts adapting.
I'll be right back.
The one in the last coaches.
Did Brawl Pro 1 or did their coach 1?
During Round Robins.
One 1 between the two of them.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
It's time.
Make it to the coaches match.
Bring us to the coaches match.
Oh.
Let's try.
I believe in you, Matt.
I will try.
Don't throw up.
I will also try.
A lot of things I'm trying here.
Shit.
Okay.
That's how we started back up.
Still have heat, too.
Nice.
Good shit.
It's a lot of damage.
He got up, run.
Good shit.
Yeah!
Okay.
I'm gonna see this in...
Jesus Christ.
I'm gonna see this in five seconds.
Whoa!
I saw it too!
Oh, we gotta launch those four twos.
Yeah, I bet.
Nice.
Keep it going.
I cannot believe that's safe.
Ha ha!
Ha!
What is this?
What is this match?
Keep on jacking it!
Jack it's so good.
Jack it harder.
Jack it real good.
And you were worried!
I gotta pull up my Tony notes.
I gotta pull them up right now.
Sorry, coach.
Hey, are you going in?
Are you going to death it?
Are you going to...
No, we'll let her rock.
You gotta do.
It's winners.
We'll let her rock.
You try to ice me like fucking Goichi, man.
It's Dragon Ball Fighters all over again.
Why'd you go bad?
He's on his Goichi shit, bro!
Like, what the fuck?
He wants the switch sides.
I can't.
That's crazy.
Yeah, rotator.
Okay.
Two more rounds.
Nice!
Okay, release.
That's fine.
Oh no, I took 30.
Okay.
Oh no!
I'm not to do 90!
Jack, Jesus, no!
Bouncer, Jack!
Oh my god, he's desperate.
Isn't it crazy how this round started with a 30% combo and
all the life is back and she's dead?
Oh my god.
Has anyone noticed?
Someone called the funeral directly.
Oh, this is...
him bro he should just stand still it's sad yeah oh no way
the fd signifier slayer the the skull crusher the bart
simpson it's your own fault oh my god oh my god is she get
her off the phone oh the sharks are hungry feed the sharks
party let's go to the Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Matt, please don't try the wall run, brother.
He wants to do what you did, coach!
Okay, okay.
Oh, okay.
Maybe we got it too cocky here.
A little too cute.
Yes.
Look, look, Matt, there's a reason why you're not the coach.
He's a bonehead.
I really am.
Got it.
He's stuck.
He flew too close.
this son oh oh she's just swinging man
oh that's true my chat was like we're just giving the
coaches time to review his notes you know we improv phone
needs for reading time all right my bad fuck you all right
well done dude what fucking anchor of the fucking team man
he's just He's just betting.
Me and Koki with the water wings on in the kitty pool.
We're like, yay.
He did it.
Yippee.
Coach, coach, coach, coach.
Yeah.
Let's get it.
Get it, baby.
He said, let's get it, bro.
Let's get it, coach.
I love you, bro, bro.
I'm going to say it.
You got that.
We love you.
Yeah, you got this, man.
is we love you brother okay that's all i needed to hear it's
true it's true we love you win or lose straight up let's go
gamers what
if he just doesn't play brian would i be freaky that would
be a throw i'm gonna use the bathroom help your back
get ready for the next battle fight
Oh Oh What a come you're at one HP by the way just to be
clear you're at one HP you're fucking him dude Yeah, it's
clean good shit turn that shit back good shit
Okay, it's all good Oh
He's a good job
Oops Hey, it's okay bro, bro.
It's okay.
I said oh Just making it close for content.
Yeah, that's right.
Play that Tekken 8, dude.
Yeah, driver's seat.
Driver's seat.
There you go, bro.
Okay.
Oh, you gotta step that.
Oh.
Let's go baby.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good shit.
Yep.
We hold back here.
Boom.
Good shit.
He's- He's so freaky.
Five seconds behind but nice!
I'm losing my eyes.
Nice.
Doc.
okay that's all right hey it was close okay very close very
close dude you can do it just play your shit what advice can
i give you here
guys you're so evenly matched
oh that tone is extra sweaty
yeah he got no wall there so i feel like you back out get
ready for the next battle i love you bro bro god it would be
so funny you accidentally come on brother bear this is easy
it's actually honestly easy i'll start giant swing that's
what i'm talking about hands weren't on the controller yet i
don't
have a dick punch okay that's all right jesus wow what a
block oh that kills him here i mean that was a good block
that's a very good block yeah
Round two, fight.
Nice.
He talked.
Oh, wow.
It's okay, dude.
You got it.
Let's go, baby.
Nice.
What a ducker.
Good kick.
Go on through floor.
Put him on the wall.
There's another area?
Okay.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
I've never seen this area before.
Good shit, dude.
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh my god.
What a crazy two hit.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Watch it.
The RDC?
Oh, okay.
Break is fucking on.
Oh my god.
Look at that break.
Oh.
Somebody needs to talk to the coach.
Oh!
Get up, Freaky Brian.
Fine, it's a little bit.
Yes!
Oh my goodness.
Let's go, dude!
Yes!
Let's go!
Maybe.
I'm gonna close my eyes.
Come on.
Oh, he's him.
Wait, what the fuck?
He's doing magic tricks.
Oh my goodness, back at the wall you go.
What?
Oh my god.
That's a fucking bait.
Are you serious?
What a fucking bait.
What do you see?
What a babe!
What is that background?
He's a fucking beast, dude.
Back out if you have to.
That's our coach!
Good fucking shit, dude.
I'm just running it back.
He's backing out to switch stages each time.
But I mean, I'm cool with it.
Let's just make sure he doesn't pick.
Make sure he doesn't pick.
It has to say random.
You did it before you could do it again.
If it doesn't say random, call him out.
Disqualified.
You know you can fight.
do it man get ready for the next battle let's get it i love
you you got this round one fight
oh my god he swapped costumes he's serious
oh he brought a gun
nice so soon nice
Faster.
Let's go, dude.
Go, coach!
Pressure!
Fuck him up!
You're better.
You're straight up better.
You're a fucking better face.
Be scared of you.
He is scared shitless.
Make him depressed.
And who wouldn't be?
Who wouldn't be scared?
I'd be pretty scared.
I'd be so scared.
smoking mirrors baby let's go smoking mirrors that's all it
is let's close it out be solid you've got to run your solid
play you got to bounce here round three fight
stage you wanted he wanted to switch stages that's what he
wanted you asked for this you wanted
Oh shit, we might have spoke too soon.
Stop kicking!
Yeah, what?
What?
Did he dunk it?
Right, okay.
Sir, please be wall.
Oh my god, is it wall?
Is it wall?
No.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Let's go!
You are my god!
Oh my god!
He's going to Evo!
That's so funny!
The good time!
It's strong for me!
Oh my god!
You literally have a smash!
The second go!
The word!
I fucking love this guy.
He's doing it every time!
Every time he does it!
How?
How does he do it every time?
Oh my god!
I'm shivering.
You tripping me, bro!
I didn't think it was possible for me to have this feeling
since last slam.
It's again, it's all over again.
Oh my god!
Keep two trips, baby!
Keep two trips!
You might have ESAM.
I don't care.
Like, put us in second.
I don't fucking care.
I don't care.
You might have ESAM, but you can't even beat our coach!
They have to win two sets now if they get to it.
Anybody has to win two sets.
We fucking got it, dude.
Yeah!
I...
I do not care.
Play your losers, come back.
Who the fuck cares?
That was Tekken.
It's literally guaranteed.
Why do you want to fight me again, Boxbox?
No, dude.
I might fight you later.
I can't.
He's about to adapt.
Oh my god.
What a thrill.
I'm done.
He's so fucking good, dude.
He's so fucking good, man.
That was insane.
Good shit, everybody.
I'm shaking, man.
Let's go.
Everybody here.
Good shit, man.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Fucking wow.
Oh, I'm sweating.
I had to close my eyes during some of those moments.
That was so fucking scary.
By definition, too hard to watch.
Oh, it's so tense.
Now imagine being the one who had to play that.
I, dude, it happened again.
We are the goats once more.
We are so fucking awesome.
Bro, bro, how did you feel?
How did you feel, bro, bro?
What do you mean?
It feels good.
It feels good now, but what do you mean?
I'm shaking the whole time.
I'm having like a seizure the whole thing.
You're fucking different, bro.
You're different.
You're different, bro.
Seriously.
He was so scared at the end.
You had him backing up, dude.
Yeah.
Yeah, the pressure fucking, you changed the tide.
You really did.
You can see it.
You saw it in the game.
Like, he was just anxious.
that coliseum it felt like it was the opposite it was the
opposite and then he should not have changed slowly you
could tell the momentum shifted yeah oh my god look at this
don't tweet somebody anymore i seriously don't care what a
clutch man oh hold on bro we gotta we gotta tweet to retweet
hold on i gotta retweet this i gotta i gotta farm my content
real quick mr two trips mr two trips i go to evo two times
send me send me again man oh two spirit oh my god yeah I
want to ride with the pilot.
Put me in the cockpit, bro.
Give me the wings.
We did it for Doki Bird.
Yeah.
We did it for Doki.
We're all getting dinner.
We are all getting dinner.
Imagine Super, how he's feeling right now.
But it didn't matter.
So he does get to come to dinner because it didn't matter.
We got up to anyway.
Oh my god, we did.
My rule was if he did it, then he's uninvited with me you
guys got a better record because you have to go to loser
bracket because last time but we're straight up yeah we have
to fight for second no we have first or second guarantee we
literally brain off i'm playing pickman bye
i've been playing four that game is so good oh my god very
good it's very crazy i heard a new pickman game is really
good that game is so fucking wait out of all the pigments
which one did you like the most yeah i go i like one i think
one or four because one is like super i didn't like two
because i didn't like the cave system but wasn't two the one
with the water the water pick the water enemy yeah that's
the one yeah that's the one what do you what are you uh
you're playing four right now yeah so i i was like hmm
should i play all of them because everyone's talking about
four and i tried one and the age got to once i played like a
modern version of pickman that was you know like made for
modern audiences i was like i fell in love i'm like this is
highly fucking good it's so it might be my favorite game
franchise it's so goddamn good dude like yeah i became a
pickman fan and i am a fan of you because you are crazy
today dude holy you are nasty this was possible because you
went you won dude that's the only way this was possible dude
and i i didn't mash wall standing for one time didn't even
do the right thing like you had to adapt to a guy who beat
you twice and you did and you did it what the was stressful
i didn't want to be the reason we didn't make it bro i was
just anxious like we're all the reason we made it we all
made it without all of us we would not have had that buy we
would have had this game we're absolutely right yep yep yep
i'm i brain off i appreciate everybody oh my god i like this
coffee so proud of you guys man seriously this Could you
imagine the timeline when we were on different teams?
I wouldn't have cared.
No, I really wouldn't have been the same vibes.
It would not.
I told you guys this.
Like, when I entered this one, they said we probably
wouldn't be together.
And I was like, alright, I'm not really going to try.
But, like, dude, I fucking cared.
I'm 100% the same.
Like, if I had any different teammates, like, I had a
different team, I would have been like, yeah, okay.
I'll try, but, you know, we cared.
But now it's just not the same.
And it really meant something.
And now Doki's here to fucking experience it.
Yeah.
One of the best teammates I've had.
I think if I was in any other team, I wouldn't be as hyped
for sure.
I would have voted in.
Seriously, unironically, we could have gotten somebody that
didn't vibe like you're in the family.
Seriously, you're in the family.
Oh, my God.
I'm in the family.
I'm talking about our team the fucking most because the
vibes fucking are insane.
Honestly, yeah, all the fans are like, oh, my God, team
brawl pros.
I'd love watching the content.
There are comms and everything.
Yeah, because we're just gamers.
Yeah, we're just vibing.
We're just gamers as well.
All these other teams are like sweating and analyzing and
trying hard.
Bro, it's five.
It's five's over here, bro.
He's Sam doing his damn, you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
You said he's so hard, but you still lost two rounds.
So if you two were like, what the fuck is?
Unironically true.
I know you're joking, but like, unironically, that's true.
From a person that has 30 in defense, like, what's wrong?
I got 58 same z's.
We all shared our stats, bro.
We all shared our stats.
Bro, yeah.
I'm showing my stream now.
I got a, I got 54 defense.
I have 54.
I was like, how do you have 30?
All offense.
All shared our shit.
I showed my chat mod.
You're like, how did you get the red with 30 defense?
I'm like, I don't know.
I'm that fucking, I'm that dude.
I don't know what to tell you.
Yeah.
I don't know how I was to tell you.
I just got there.
I punched.
Yeah, we fight.
$70 just to not play the game?
Get out of here.
That's what I'm saying, man.
We fight in this motherfucker.
Take your sensitive ass back to Street Fighter.
Wow.
What a fucking dopamine rush.
You do damage, bro.
What's going on?
Something about, like they're fighting on shit?
I don't fucking care.
Yeah, I'm watching CJ.
Bro, bro, bro.
The fact that you keep getting put in these situations he
just literally doing it literally it's remarkable like
you're due for a loss it's unbelievable crazy and they
studied you too and you so beat their ass i'm gonna enter
online attorneys now because that pressure is nothing like
this pressure yeah seriously man yeah this is the second
time you've done it you're getting used to it yeah that's
like free content now let me just enter those winner lose
that's not it's nothing like this there's no pressure bro
you got it it's like i don't even think like evo would be as
much pressure because the thing is with this there's an
expectation to win i don't expect to win evo right yeah like
here we could fucking win yeah fucking dead well well well
yeah okay to be fair first or second we know the fans will
remember us only yeah yeah the fans will remember us they'll
remember us we can That's what I'm saying.
All right.
Don't tell me I got to fight Amaz though.
Because we will go second.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, SK got a round off.
Logan.
Oh, my God.
SK got to 10-year-old?
All right, fellas.
I'm going to death him for a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
Talk your shit.
I am so sweaty right now.
even the ac is on full blast and i know my temperature
increased yeah i feel it my bloodstream i gotta go turn that
up make the temperature lower holy i could feel the sweat
coming from both coaches yeah you know you know ali right i
he came in my chat he was like hey uh i just asked him hey
you're going to evo because i know he snipes you all the
time you guys are like buddy buddy whatever i don't really
know lord but whatever and obviously i already had a ticket
so i said hey you're going to evo he said no so i said hey
if we win we get top two i give you mine you're gonna he's
going to evo points if his parents let him he's 19.
all right well that's also i mean like i was not told this
information dude he he he's in well i mean chicago's a big
place he's in chicago he can't go to combo breaker because
his parents so i don't know i don't the lore maybe they've
talked it out i don't know if if he's allowed to i'll i mean
i'll you know yeah i'll give him my ticket if say jam allows
it of course you know there's there's quote-unquote we'll
demand for it no fight for you i i do want to i want to send
i want to send him to evo fuck it because what else am i
going to do with my ticket holy this tournament has been so
fucking hyped though oh my god i certainly never been this
nervous before and i'm not even playing some of these games
actually crazy
it's actually crazy though guys I can't believe it we made
it to the final
we made it to the finals guys
that's insane I did not expect it I felt like I had like the
least experience out of everybody here and then I get to be
in the finals on this yeah i was the moral support
yeah i'm happy i like specifically requested brawl pro too
to be my coach so i'm really happy that like i decided to
play king you know i i don't know i don't even know how we
got into me becoming a king player but like um the fact that
like uh i i like just randomly decide king will be my my
character to play in this tournament and then because of
that i specifically requested a brawl pro for uh for like my
coach because i was like oh he's a king player that would
make sense yeah and then it's destiny it was wait so we have
a hell of a time to chill now yeah yeah they gotta do kfm
versus vdx then whoever wins that fights tone then they
fight us yeah yeah so we have to wait
hanging out i'm mad chilling i'm gonna watch that box box
match and see how much i smoked him ego boost myself i'm so
scared of him though like he's so solid now he got so much
oh my god it's actually crazy yeah and he requested me too
apparently bra pro like requested for me as well because i
was fucking around on king and and it's just it's just crazy
i'm very i'm really happy i got this team and like and happy
that because they were there for the first stage i'm slammed
they got all got together and i was like the plus the what
plus one and i'm just really happy to be able to meet these
guys it's been such cool vibes i haven't grinding this hard
in the in a game in a long time like last night i was just
playing rink and i was so toxic to uh because i was just
like i want to
I think I think the reason why people like even though I'm
in red rank and getting like sort of demolished is also
because I feel like um I feel like they actually analyze how
I play and then I'm just like I go rank I do allocate I
think that is like my biggest weakness I don't adapt is
adapting and I'm just like Ali kick good old but then what
do I do what do I do when they learn the when they learn the
analyze
what do I do and that's when I get absolutely demolished I'm
actually surprised I still took two rounds off Isam and then
he adapted and then I don't adapt.
I just go Ungabungo, but what if it works again?
I was like, okay, but what if this works again and he
doesn't adapt?
I was just like, oh, okay.
Wow, this guy actually knows what he's doing.
Yeah, I think definitely the 30 defense defense did not help
the 30 defense was definitely here in my counter there uh
yeah i'm happy that i managed to i feel like i don't know i
know like because like i feel really happy to be able to
make it to red rank um it was just i think like it says how
many hours i have in this game how many well to be fair a
lot of it is just buffer where we're waiting but it says
here how many hours i have right yeah 53 hours in like 53
hours i uh i got like well i want to say like fifth forward
50 less than 50 50 hours because we've spent a lot on just
waiting so i think like maybe like 50 hours or less to red
rank i feel like that's really good in general um and like
for my very first uh for my first uh uh 45 yeah maybe 45 i'd
say 45 hours not counting like all the the waiting and the
practice and the just the practice range and the crashes i
feel like that's really good for a new player anyway that's
my ego boost today the fact that i got to this rank with
with like 50 hours i feel like i improved a lot um and like
i basically kept so many actual fight like fighting play
fighting game players too um because of the bullshit i do
because i know there's like so many people that are like
actual hardcore grind fighting games and like they're like
hard stuck in like lower eels like that fucking king player
i bumped into that made it to purple rank and it took him
like one and a half months and i'm like That's sad.
I'm sorry if you guys I'm not talking about you guys chat Of
course, it's not you guys, but the ones that had like TTV in
their names and they Have the streaming tag and then I Like
looked at their stream and I just see like Just made it a
purple rank and I Like looked at a one and a half months ago
They were hard stuck red for one And a half months and I'm
like that's so Sad I'm literally like two ranks away From
purple
But not you guys I'm not talking I get what you guys, I'm
talking to that one random purple king I saw yesterday.
They're just like me.
But I'm so happy.
We made it to the grand finals.
We're currently waiting.
All right, let me put the text out.
I'll put a text out so people would know.
We are, we made it to finals.
waiting for our game right now.
Okay, I'll put that text up so people will know.
Yeah!
So people will know we're just waiting.
We made it to finals!
The grand finals!
Okay, yeah, you're right.
Grand finals.
We made it to grand finals.
finals there you go so people will know so people will know
i should put it in the middle that makes more sense actually
boom wait let me uh format it better too yeah
there you go yay we made it i will be your new fighting game
oh she as i never touched Tekken after this.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll touch Tekken until I make it to Purple Ring just
to flex a little and then never touch it again.
Make it to Purple Ring just to be like it's sad that you
guys can't be in this ring.
No, please continue.
If Seijam invites me to another Seijam Slam, I'll 100% say
yes.
Or for any fighting game.
If Seijam invites me to any fighting game Slam, I'll
participate.
I'll say yes 100%.
Peek purple and then start flexing.
I should.
I should just peek purple and be like, oh, imagine not being
purple.
He said my...
Oh, I never played well like I said never played any
fighting game before so like like like I never played Street
Fighter before I told well, that's a lie.
I played like, you know the arcade arcade machines or the
Street Fighter Or the Street Fighter with Marvel characters?
I would go to I got went to the arcade and I just button
matched for that So like that was my I was like super young
too, but if Seijam invites me to the Street Fighter The
Street Fighter Say Jam Slam.
I'll say yes.
I mean, I'll message him and be like, I'm totally down to
joining in.
But please put me in newbies.
And give me actual newbies.
I want to be the next ESAM.
Make me the next ESAM.
I want to know what it feels like.
Wishful thinking
No, I'm still a newbie You can't say that I'm not a newbie
anymore I still don't know how to block Wait, that's not
fair Connor was supposed to Connor was supposed to be in the
say jam slab And he was in the last say jam slab And he was
categorized as a newbie it's not fair I should be like the
next Connor he was categorized as a newbie even though he
like couldn't commit it's not fair I should be a newbie
because my blocking stats are still like the newbie tier
like my attack might be red but my block is definitely like
beginner or first down or some shit my My block is
definitely in first down.
True.
Yeah, so like, I am a newbie.
I am a newbie, guys.
It's not fair.
Look, it's not fair.
This is my first fighting game.
I should still be in, like, the last seed.
Or, what is it, first seed?
What is it called?
The last seed?
um yeah i think i learned really fast i'm really happy that
i learned so fucking fast though who's winning at the moment
guys you guys know who's winning at the moment oh team fee
team fee oh but then they have like roy who roy is
apparently really good too um so oh my god it's dragon ball
Wait, Roy is getting his...
Wait, Roy is...
Yeah, Roy has to win that because Roy...
Roy is definitely not...
Does not belong in this...
In that seed.
Roy definitely doesn't belong in the seed.
It's okay, guys.
I will represent the VTubers.
I...
I will represent the VTubers in the finals.
it's okay
wait does no I meant like if they don't win if they don't
get into the finals I will be the vtuber representative
I said if I didn't say when guys I didn't say when I said if
so I'm giving them them a chance
I'm so excited also the rare Zaxedon because we haven't had
a chance to actually talk together for a while guys because
like last week or like this week if you want to say Sunday
is the start of the new week or the end of the week it was
like my technically it was my chill week where I like
basically play Tekken so it's nice to be able to finally
like actually talk to you guys and everything um but oh my
god what an eventful week even though like it was
technically chill week being able to participate in stage m
slam and like uh having stage m invite me to participate i'm
so happy that he invited me to participate because like i
honestly i i had no expectations i guess about it like i was
just like oh i'm so bad at fighting games i'm i'm gonna drag
my team down I was so scared then it like like being in the
team got me super motivated to like get better and improve
and stuff and being able to to just like playing fighting
games for real for the first time and actually learning
combos was really fun it was really fun I think it wasn't
with any other team I wouldn't feel as passionate as I did
so I'm just happy I got it Included.
Oh.
Yeah.
I think if I wasn't so nervous when I was playing against
Gumi, I think I could have won that.
I was so nervous.
I was, because like, I, I was thinking.
I need to remember to stop thinking.
Yeah.
Because that's what got me here.
I need to remember to stop thinking.
Because I got all the punishes correct.
I got all the blocks correct, but I did nothing afterwards.
I forgot how to kill afterwards.
Yeah, the tournament nerds definitely got me in that game,
but we still clutch.
Guys, but if I did it, if I won that game, we would not have
got, we wouldn't have got a fucking insane coach game,
though.
So I'm happy I lost.
So we got the sickest coach game ever with the fucking wall
jump.
That shit was crazy.
Oh my god.
The coach plays out.
We would have missed out, guys.
We would have 100% missed out on the fucking jump.
Bro, the fucking wall jump was out.
actually crazy.
Oh my god.
That's fun.
That's so fun.
I love...
I was looking at the...
I was actually...
I was looking at the tags.
That's the tag.
The birdseater tag.
And I like posted it in our team chat.
But I love the...
Doki versus Esam was closer.
But...
wait the jack the jack versus the jack versus asuka that was
fucking brutal
oh my god oh yeah great time
oh hey jack sorry that was the freaking massacre.
I'm happy.
I'm so happy, though.
What are your favorite moments chat so far?
I think like first or second, I really don't care if we get
first or second.
I think like like no matter what first and second is sort of
like the same prize.
It's the same prize because we made it to the finals and
like honestly I don't really care if we get first or second
just because like I had so much fun with my team in the end.
Um Yeah!
Bro, it's like the- I swear, like the- The Kony King Mirror
was like the slowest king fight I've ever seen.
It's so- It's like actually it's like the two kings just
fucking thinking about what to do.
It's- It's so slow!
I was like, please!
I can't take it!
I can't take such slow king fights!
it was so intense it's literally rock paper scissors yeah i
would never be that patient if a king made me wait that long
i i fucking you can have it you deserve it like you deserve
that matchup
yeah it was a chess match it was honestly all right yeah roy
won their fight i mean it was obvious that Roy was going to
win that fight.
Not going to lie.
It was so like, Roy is really good at... Was that character,
the main character buff?
He literally has the main character buff.
But FD wins this.
Oh wait, FD might win this.
So it's Team FD.
Gin buff is real.
Yeah, but how well are you going to do against Tone's team?
I feel like Tone's team is definitely like... I think it was
like has to be the major upset because Tone's team is
actually, it is so fucking good.
I feel like Tone's team has, like Tone's team was supposed
to be in the flatness because none of us, all of us was
like, oh yeah, we're definitely going to go to the loser
brackets after winning, winning that.
We were like, oh yeah, definitely, we're not going to win
against Tone.
So the fact that we did was definitely has to be a huge
upset for Tone.
Uh, yeah.
I was so surprised.
yeah their team is really fucking good so i feel like like
fee versus tone i don't know unless they didn't study fee's
team and just heavily studied our team i feel like tone's
team would win uh yeah it had it had to be a major upset
like even our team was like oh yeah we're not gonna we're
not gonna we're gonna be in the loser brackets though They
were the favorites.
No, 100%.
I feel that we're going to play against ESAM again.
And ESAM will...
ESAM will adapt.
You guys want to play some couple of games while we wait?
I mean, we don't really...
Alright.
Let's do some games with the goons.
Alright, guys.
Boot up the Tekken.
Guys, it's time to boot up some Tekken.
Create session.
beating up goon oh wait
okay wait maybe not
meaning beating up people there you go all right beating up
people okay connection three or better any we're one and
done people guys all right this is the all right doing
custom doing customs until maybe this funny was beating
doing customs until our game our final our grand final
starts okay
let's see name beating up people password will be one zero
zero let's see where's the advanced settings passcode one
there you go nobody will know how would they know all right
create all right i'm gonna watch i'm gonna use the bathroom
so you guys can like fight each other first i'll be right
back
get ready for the next battle
round one fight all right let's go all right who's gonna win
this the the king player or the the fucking victor crutch
all right if you don't win this you better fucking win this
with an alley kick or you're not true king main you better
end this with an alley kick give us give the people what
holy okay that was sick though that was pretty sick Wait,
what?
Where is my alley kick?
Wait, come on.
Entertain us.
Okay, yeah, that was fucking sick.
The dunk though?
The dunk was pretty fucking sick, not gonna lie.
Oh.
I can't go.
Kaz is going crazy oh no this king this team might be like
me 30 defense this could be a this could be a 30 defense
king oh just team fee one I'm not surprised.
Hally the Hally.
There's a 30 defense.
Oh, Team Fee got eliminated.
Oh.
Okay, so Team Fee got eliminated, so it's, uh, so I have to
fight Logan.
If they're, if Kauai team wins, uh, oh, no.
Oh, KFM.
Sorry, not Fee.
God damn it!
I got confused!
Okay, Fee won, so it's, uh, SKC.
wait is amaz is amaz is on uh which team is amaz on
there's so many names
okay because like i know like they said they did oh that's
good that's good because like my team didn't want to fight
amaz you win
all right nice you didn't even end it with an alley kick
you're not a real king player all right let me in i'm ready
let me in somebody let me in cause you you leave now guys
don't make me kick you out because i will do it all right
cause oh wait no you guys didn't fight me wait no i fought
you Kaz Lee already fought you in members
You think I don't remember I already fought you in member
And you lost anyway losers has to leave If you lose you
leave It's the way of the law It's the way of the Tekken lad
Bro It's the public humiliation Wait What did Seijam say
about like a fucking ticket?
All right, here we go.
Nothing yet.
He said, I thought he said that Eva wants to send everyone
no matter what.
Is that what he said?
Oh my god, it's me!
With those shoes?
I was trying to see what Tony was saying about me.
What the fuck?
What's wrong with you?
You're bad from the Doki Council.
So talented.
Doki's need to wear shoes.
The Doki Prime declares that all Doki's need to wear shoes.
What's wrong with you?
Matt, I think he said he might send the third place or
something?
What the fuck?
I said send us next year.
But I mean, I'm just kidding.
We're free?
Exactly!
How dare you give this for free and not monetize it?
What's wrong with you, Doki?
This is it.
You get the alley kick special.
I can't believe it This is why all the other dokees don't
like you
That's fucking right Remember this Remember this That's
fucking right And you get alley kicked Oh wait I did that
wrong And you get alley kicked Goodbye Wait what?
Oh anyone who has uh entered so that's i mean that's 200
bucks that's still really solid but i was like wait what you
just get to go for free no matter what i was confused okay
that makes more sense yeah leave metty leave or i kick you
where is he yeah we have your zero wins Fucking good luck,
man.
I can't believe Brawl Pro plays like that.
And then PDX was like, he's for real.
Like, what do you mean?
Plays like what?
Let me know when... Okay.
I don't know, we should watch the last one.
Let me know when the last one starts.
I'll fight like three more people and then we're gonna see
the final match.
Yeah.
I mean, I'll still play my heart.
out but like i'm ready to i'm ready all right king versus
king don't be slow okay all right we i can't deal with slow
king fights i really can i'm too impatient for that you're
gonna play uh a thousand year door okay that's gonna nice
right oh i told you i helped like i have it on my oh wait
you actually oh my god no please please remember we had that
don't block chat would you watch no i said don't block
what's wrong with you no what's wrong with you that's your
that's right this is what you get for blocking i can't let
that okay we'll play ranked man yeah real king players don't
block what is wrong with you you where's your fucking 30
defense king like what what's wrong banish him banish him
from the king council as well you block and you're still in
gary rank like bro that's embarrassing you should be like
higher rank right now how am i give higher rank than you
when you actually know how to play this character like
that's so embarrassing that's all i'm saying
i don't know it's his first day no this does not seem like a
first day king
He can defense, but no shin you?
Exactly.
What the fuck's your shin are you?
All right, leave.
All right, so one of you guys has to let me in.
One of you guys has to let me in.
Guys, what are you guys at?
Are you watching?
like match was having tracking is insane tony's watching i
think but he's sorry i only played rick for two days oh now
he's fucking flexing oh yeah i played rick for only one day
never lied i never lied
esam versus sk is starting okay we'll beat up this bear What
the fuck?
Are you actually new?
We'll find out.
Alright.
Oh, he doesn't know how to skip cutscenes.
Guys, you can tell I fixed my PC.
So nobody can complain anymore.
I had to underclock my PC hard.
I fixed it, though.
the solution that's not fixing it is nobody noticed people
were like oh my god she's on her new PC and I was like yeah
but now I had to confess because like I can't lie
I had to confess to you guys because I would never lie to
you guys about it you know oh my god what the fuck
You guys did not know shit.
Don't lie.
You guys did not know that I was using my old PC.
Because it looked good.
It looked so good.
Okay, somebody has to fucking stop.
Nope.
This is why your environment's dying.
Bro.
This is why.
why.
We're hunting you down.
You'll have nowhere to live.
What is he doing?
I ducked!
Try to be like slime.
He lost every...
Oh, I shouldn't say that.
He's a good teammate because I also lost every game today.
I also lost every...
game today i'm no better i'm no better slime's a great
teammate oh oh slime you get your run back maybe now with
john oh wait did i nice no not nice not nice no i feel
into a headspace that made me just want it to roast
everybody.
I'm so sorry.
Whenever I'm at a...
When I play Tekken, it's hard to stop.
Like, there's nobody safe.
Nobody's safe from me.
That's why.
Nice.
Okay.
Just nobody is safe.
Everybody gets hurt.
Losing to a first done?
You know that guy was not actually a first done.
This guy fucking played before.
This is not their first fighting game.
This guy was not their first one.
Learn a combo first before.
I don't need to learn a combo.
I could get it away with you.
it until i can't okay if i don't know combos it's because my
coach didn't coach me hard enough all right
all right oh you're right i know one combo i know one combo
guys that's all i need to do
I know one combo that's all I need I just need to know one
Oh what the fuck Oh my god fucking Victor crutch Using a
crutch That's fucking That's not right What the fuck Okay
this is not fair He's literally blue ring That's not fair
Stop Stop Stop I'm just right!
Bro!
Get away from me.
Oh, and you just got a roll?
You bitch.
Yeah, you're a bitch.
Fuck you.
all right get out using a victor crutch get out get out
oh i need to remember that he does that oh my god i knew
that was an easy low i'm learning i'm learning oh please i'm
not learning anymore i'm not learning anymore
I stopped learning.
There's like a point where I just suddenly stopped learning
because it's like too much.
You know, like pay a subscription to start learning more,
guys?
I used up all my data.
I used up my subscription data.
It was like 5 gigabytes and all that 5 gigabytes was gone.
Let me back in.
back in the free sample has ended your monthly your free
monthly subscription has ended okay this is the last one
it's very possible that we play team PDX I mean SK and Isam
are tied they're tied oh shit oh my god they're tied SK is
punishing the slide how did she do it she I mean she's
blocking it then she's doing while standing for she's
Blocking?
For real.
Poppro, why didn't you teach me that?
I literally tried for like two days straight.
This is why my defense is at 30.
Oh my.
It's a fear.
How is she blocking?
Just so we can say we beat all the other teams.
maybe I don't know I would love to not play Josh again I'll
say that much I mean you'd have to fight by freaking
Fairlight dude good dog it yes I'll fight freaky thing way
if you launch his shoulder man i mean oh i can't i'm on the
wrong side sk is probably gonna take this maybe oh my god i
don't know if you guys are watching this probably i'm on the
wrong side you're doing electrics and stuff all right all
right after make this quick we need to watch the sk match
make this quick okay i'm watching it in the side I'm
watching this on the side right now.
Okay, if I lose, it's because I wasn't paying attention.
I need you to know that, okay?
It's not anything else.
I was not paying attention.
Alright, nice.
Boop.
Now that's embarrassing for you.
Yay.
Oh, please.
Why aren't you winning?
This is how I farm the Reds.
You're a good example of how I farm all of you.
Thank you for demonstrating.
Oh shit, I'm sorry, I did not mean that.
JK, I meant it.
Yeah.
I meant it all.
No!
Hurry!
Oh shit, don't hurry.
Wait, she didn't hit that!
Oh no.
Guys, I'm not paying attention because I have to watch the
game!
Ah!
There you go.
No, please.
i'm not paying attention all right jake i lost on purpose so
i can watch the game wait sk1 okay sk just won she just
destroyed these things it's her tail freaking destroyed him
last round though last round oh it's last to play it's a
perfect all right guys we're leaving to watch now
we're gonna watch uh where is okay
uh watching
to see who we fight
in finals okay nice replace all right sorry we couldn't play
a lot of customs
wait the sk like win for her team or do you have to do one
more i think she just won she won the first game she beat
esam hmm what's good fellas we back they're still they're
still gaming yeah yeah i want for you to win so bad bro i
definitely could take fd i think yeah okay so like what was
what was sk's like uh weakness because i had no i did not
realize i was gonna be fighting sk If you have no idea, then
you know what?
Just run your shit.
Okay, AliKick.
Maybe.
Yes.
Nope, AliKick it is.
Breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
Yes, sir.
Coach, what do I do?
You never prepared me for SK.
Um.
Hold on.
Let me watch some tapes.
Wait, Radis is going crazy.
Whoa.
Does anyone have the, um, oh, never mind.
I got it.
The chart.
How do we do against Team Fee in, uh, two days ago?
Or one.
It was me.
So we're, we're way better off against them.
Yeah.
Wait, only Doki lost?
Yeah, I lost to SK.
I got like one round offer.
We, I think we three-tued a different day.
Like we three-tued.
than them for one but yeah i see i think mix
nice no way she went for that giant maiden at work that's
sick she got a round off uh we went three two day one
against them then four one yeah yeah i'm way more confident
against them i mean we can't beat tony obviously but
tony's team is just tiny is just stressful i feel like it
went two sets so i think it's because their team all like
analyzed us but they didn't really analyze each other sure I
feel like possible because I know a lot of them were
hard-grinding against our
characters wait why is he deep hacking her oh yeah that's so
toxic I didn't see it I saw it man maybe Riz just annoyed
that you beat him it's taking out his anger somewhere else
that's true he's like I was very disrespectful in my shit.
I feel bad.
I was so annoyed after we watched those tapes last night,
dude.
Like, I was like, dude, he's doing one thing.
Yeah.
You lost to the Hayachi gatekeeper.
Hayachi gatekeeper?
I'm about to fight Hayachi and Dragonel walks in for it.
Wait.
He's a bot.
Dude, that's mad disrespectful to say about him.
I know.
I know, but I was so fucking mad, dude.
Oh.
Oh, man.
Oh, my God.
She's kind of...
She's going crazy.
Are we sure we want to bend this team?
We blocked this.
I'm way more confident against Kat than Reed.
It's because Kat kind of gets scrambled against pressure.
Yeah, she gets really flustered against a lot of offense.
Remember the last thing he thought?
Oh, good break.
Fucked on her.
Not going to lie.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no, wait.
No.
What if I tackle you back?
That's crazy.
Oh,
Bro's got his bowl out.
That's a really nice wig.
He can't even tell, bro.
Goes into the sideburns too.
That looks nice.
The technology is kind of crazy.
It's all that Chipotle money.
He's got it out because he knows he's saving money now that
horse hair what is that horse hair that looks good slime
truth i've had slime truth pinned all his dreams at the top
that's the best i've ever seen in my life dude you had to
watch it when he made that in real time that was the funny
dude the photoshop like ai i asked it to make him bald and
it delivered me so good I mean, maybe AI isn't so bad, bro.
I literally was like, you know what?
This is a good application of this.
We worked with the machines.
Dude, slime.
It's a utopia.
At first, you were like, you were like, make him bald.
And then they turned him into a stock image, shrugging.
And he was still crazy.
Yeah, it's funny.
And then to fix it, you said, make his head bald.
Oh, and it fixed it.
I'm like, what the fuck is this?
It's an imperfect technology.
If it comes to it specifically, making sayjam bald i support
it only for that make his head bald it's so redundant but it
works yeah come on cat if cat wins this they only need one
more set yeah yeah he's gonna send it oh no way she could
have just oh he's dead that's it dude oh no way no way she
chokes oh no way no way she could have won that she's
probably i mean super stressed you know what i mean yeah i
mean like they're the underdogs you know so tone's team
might be on tilt from from what happened with our arms on
tail the tones on tilt 100 i was definitely on tail with the
way he was trying to like you could see it to lose yeah i
think the team is on till after what what we demolished them
demolished last yeah yeah that's three to two demolish
that's a lot i'll call it out is rage art yeah that was the
most obvious rage he just pops it raiders just lets it go
hey if it worked it worked right that gives the set i mean i
let her rock too yeah yeah no i'm not saying there's
anything wrong with it it's like it's great especially with
how much pressure cat like just keeps running up but it's a
good spot yeah the the harder you go and second the more
it'll be like plus frames dashed up wait you know because
you're afraid of the rage art yeah you know then the mind
games start and it gets fucking scary yeah please fee please
dude that Chipotle unironically looks good did you guys
already use your free code dude I used my code for lunch
today and I just saw a text message from my wife she was
like hey I got you a Chipotle burrito it's on the stove we
didn't even talk like she just got it so now I got another
one ready what the fuck that's lunch tomorrow you need to
fully sponsored your wife no oh I love this stage shit nice
the last round lol dude the moment he didn't fucking take
muscle buster I was like oh it's over did you hear yeah dude
no it was an offense yeah it's relentless there's gaps
though everything he's doing except for that move everything
else he's doing there's a gap jeez dick jab is your fan
against ravers like that he's doing four four yeah you can
back three him in between or you can jab to float him what's
four you can duck that point it out when you see it i don't
know what it is okay sure he did it on you a few times if i
can yeah see his one-to-one worked after because the third
hit is uh that's a high it's plus if you block it she's
fumbling
That's good.
Yeah, so the thing about Ray is, you see, he does like that
double hammer down, right?
And it's he plus and he kind of fucks on you.
Like he always does something that is not still real
afterwards.
Like he'll take an extra, extra long move.
So just dick jab after you see that, honestly, and you
fucking, you beat him.
Because he takes too many turns.
He's like, oh, I'm hella plus.
Let me do an even more slower move.
But it's not airtight, you know?
That's my issue is I don't know how to take my turn back
consistently against him.
it's like if i can't land the power push he's just oh my god
mix oh my god mix he's just down two dude we gotta block
that we can't let him win with that stupid move it's
literally all he's doing that's the most fraudulent drag
i've ever seen oh my god that was tight though but she's
crazy because that's what we talked about is like anytime i
get hit while standing for and then i just forget like when
i'm in game i'm like uh yeah minus on hit yeah i mean if he
again if he notices you're doing the while setting four
after he can counter plate but is rated to doing that you
know no not not at this he's not gonna he's not gonna he's
not in grand finals like he's been getting away with it so
long you know yeah just match four if you just see the move
at all you know block or hit block you get a punish hit you
probably get a punish who does josh have to play did he beat
this guy last time uh josh uh fairlight thanks yeah fair
Fairlight's strong.
This is in favor of Fee, I think.
I don't have the things.
So it'd be Fee, Tony, which... Which is a...
They played earlier, and then...
Oh, and then Tony had sent him to losers.
Yeah.
At the tournament.
Wait, how did we 4-1 this team?
Oh, but Boxbox, though.
Slime... Slime beat Fairlight?
No.
No, that fang is nasty.
Wait, then we did it 4-1.
I beat Kat.
She beat...
I didn't beat S.
She beat S-Gay.
No, I didn't BSK.
Oh, you didn't?
No, no.
I only bait Logan.
I'm just straight up lies.
Logan and Amour.
Maybe we just three-twoed them.
Okay.
Because I know you beat Fee.
He beat FD.
And I beat Cat Link.
Oh, okay.
So we just three-three-two.
Might be three-two's.
Slime can beat Fairlight.
Is this Slime paying attention?
Slime, are you even paying attention, Slime?
His ass better be watching, true.
He's watching more melee.
I respect it.
Is he actually...
Okay, I'm like...
Come on, man.
Hey, man.
Grunt said it.
fine ranked all right all right all right yeah he's fighting
a shall you right now oh yeah don't don't worry about shall
you the fucking character is stupid oh oh i know i hate that
guy you might have to play fairlight uh slime i mean to be
fair fd box box is a mix up their games are so close every
time right oh i see we don't know how it'll go yeah i'm just
you know what i'm just enjoying the matches i'm taking my
break holy nice fair light guy is a is goofy with these
combos combos snake edge to catch the rules these raijin
like strats are crazy like the shit that i see working oh my
god he just cooked this man slime you gotta you gotta watch
your old honest abe you're doing very honest strings mr
president can't very honest strings indeed this guy
definitely does not know what the fuck is this what the fuck
let him get up oh he did that's so nice of him just to beat
him up again okay oh no he's about to okay he did the good
pose all right i thought he was about to do something i had
to turn the camera other pose coney oh you know the other
you've seen it i don't like that one the double l's is fine
the other one is is it all over or is it just not yet no no
no he just won one one one one round yeah yeah but that was
a three oh though no yeah i don't think josh knows fang at
all so it's probably gonna be a lot oh i see rune okay but
slime you can see the things that the fairlight is doing and
he's the same rank as you i mean yeah doable and slime you
never do while running one two into bear stance and to the
grab you never yeah i so i got into matchmaking to practice
that to get used to that because i realized it is not
something i've been doing we got more fun i did it today
shall you twice got it remember yeah bear stance one plus
two it's you just throw it up actually when joshua went so
bad i don't want to play him but i can't i can't root
against him here yeah he's yeah of course i mean i want
joshua bro yeah i jumped I mean, I want Josh to lose, but,
you know, he's a sweetheart.
I love the guy, but I just hope as many people come to Evo
as possible, win or lose whoever, you know.
Absolutely, yeah.
He's a sweetheart, dude.
When he first saw me in Slime's chat, he's like, oh, slime.
That's a dick rider.
Bro, bro, I'm like, what?
I was like, that's, I'm like, that's my student brother.
What have you seen?
I gotta, I gotta hype him up.
Yeah, he's, he barks a lot, but it's, zero bite that does
not look like brian this skin is disarming like that's a
normal guy you know about magic the gathering commercial in
like the 90s where they're like what's this about and
they're like cool rad dudes uh i'll link it he looks like
that he looks like one of that those guys i mean i could
such a specific reference he looks like a guy from a mentos
commercial is that you're gonna instantly get it i i feel
like i can already imagine the commercial based on what
saying what oh my god these guys are gaming they're just
punching each other oh my god he looks like the guy from
streets of rage oh axel kind of that's just a white shirt
who's he supposed to be isn't he supposed to be someone is
he leon leon but like leon the weird streetwear leon 90s
leon what the is this commercial it's like a uh it's like an
mtv spot actually for magic the gathering dude i'm gonna
keep it a hundred dollars with you i've never seen this this
is insane yeah i didn't know it either until i started
watching magic the gathering youtube which i don't play the
game pony young confirmed i feel like i have a question
because you're as old as me did you used to watch like mtv
springberry it could be like hell yeah that's gonna be me
someday no i used to no you know what i used to watch i
wanted to be so cool i i watched it and i said i hate this i
wanted to go back to normal mtv barely barely one by the way
you didn't watch like singled out and we're hell yeah jenny
no i thought it was cringe except my friend's sister who had
a crush on she liked blink 182 so we would watch mtv
together she'd be like oh my god let's watch mtv spring
break i'd be like yeah of course i love that yeah i used to
watch that shit with like you know the big stage i was like
damn one day i'm gonna be a cool 21 year old on spring break
and like it just never happened what happened you know what
i mean i played brawl instead yeah i think you went like
opposite direction yeah yeah i the hardest opposite
direction you possibly could have yeah besides becoming
amish wow fees team is all streaming in discord that's so
weird oh they're they're hard like coaching like live
coaching maybe that's all i took it there's no delay and
i'll play against freaky brian i hear nothing from brawl pro
bro i hear i hear i hear crickets from him dude i don't want
to i just want freaky bro he's too freaky i want freaky
answers and i get nothing i want to say so much but i don't
want to throw you off dude the goosebumps threatened bro if
you cut that high you'll get a freaky launcher yeah just say
it like that yeah yeah if i'm not shit go extra high wait
pay attention matt pay attention matt what do you mean pay
attention oh dude this is freaky eddie what do you mean oh
yeah he's gonna pull an eddie on you yeah bro we're talking
freaks like dude you're gonna fight this like none of us
train for this sickle mode like combos and stuff damage oh
my god three eddie's freaky too man when he gets on his
hands if he feels a little like freaky he goes with too yeah
right eddie players be like oh my god two how about a punch
oh my god armor let me use my hands for one second the mid
bro i love this stage this i think it goes low seven billion
times no no but does he know i was gonna say has does he
have experience knowing that that's safe if charges like
it's not just i mean plus it's unfair oh okay boom it's hers
her no heat i don't know what if he wins this then they wow
yeah then we fight them yeah this gotta hurt so bad because
like evo's on the line here so like this guy this is what we
were experiencing right yeah this is this is now right yeah
i feel like pro mk match yeah i i feel like total team
didn't at all box box doki i don't think you're wrong man i
i think seriously people like trained for us because that
happened last time too so yeah because i did not expect
tone's team to not do that well against v's team yeah
because they knew all our share i was like what the yeah
nice dude and box box really wanted the win yeah don't don't
don't play one more set one more set for the boys and they
spin that shit
damn so maybe they just focused on us yeah yeah do we know
how to fight against fees team like we won three two which
means it was a coach match all right bro bro you ready
that's assuming i beat fd and last time that was shit was
Literally one hit.
We'll see.
But I know the matchup better now.
And so, in the end, the fans will remember us as first place
winners.
We will rewrite history again.
Oh, another silver medal, eh?
I can't take it.
I just want to win.
You better be watching.
You better watch the Farlight fight then.
I really actually should.
all right hey that's that stupid fucking uh like wall
standing for this fake a shit right he just did he just did
it twice right bro bro coach i'm here i'm sorry dude i'm
sorry coach the one time i asked you a question is it real
or is it not real young man one question throughout the
entire stage am slam and the first one you're not here if fd
signifier did it it's not real bro oh my
dude they're posting ASCII art and I had to ban them sorry
oh my goodness was it bald Mario smoking a cigarette no it
was just titties the old standbyes honestly the classic oh
my god what is that crazy rager what did he do matt matt
what did he do that he was doing the the stupid like down
back three and then while standing four and you're like
that's minus five and he's taking his turn at the launch
right okay that's heat smash yes no it wasn't because he
still had his heat oh got you okay also man he stopped doing
it i haven't seen him do that one time yet that's not did it
twice that's not that that right there that's fake as even
if the first yeah down forward two if he hits you with that
low but he is finishing that string sometimes which he gets
a free crouch throw after i'm just dude box might get me the
out of here i don't want to put get me out help Freaky.
Freaky Eddie is real.
Yeah, really.
Eddie is like that guy you find in Sekiro in like the really
small area with the claws, like the Centipede guy.
Like that's how I watch him.
Like the guy you got to parry eight million times.
Oh, I hate that guy.
Oh my God.
What a parry.
Oh, he fell over a razor.
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh, did he miss?
Damn, dude.
Oh, well, we're playing against Fees team.
What a way to lose, man.
that sucks damn dude we gate kept we actually gate kept we
did what we said we were gonna do we gate kept no you guys
did it for esam we are no evil for esam yo yeah we are the
most toxic team i love it here that's what you get for
smurfing yeah fucking esam yeah that's what you get for
wanting it so bad yeah and for what just wait just let it
come to your lap we can't we have jack jesus jack jesus is
the most valuable ore found in any mine ever it's mithril
yeah it's like i just watched that big robot get on the
screen and i'm like it's just gonna be a good day he's so
fun to watch that was true like you like look at look away
for one second and then 80 the health is gone i'm
considering bringing out the cost at kicks brawl pro
thoughts and once again once again follow here no no i'm
done with you bro bro bro bro if if we lose actually your
fault i hate how dare you not cost that there it is don't do
it do that move where you sit on your butt and then you
swing your arms a lot that's what i was kind of oh my god
yes there's more fan art try that oh my god that fan art's
sick i'm retweeting this one too there's a lot of good fan
art bro wait we got more fan art yeah there's like four yeah
oh new ones oh shit hold on i gotta check them out i like
damn these are sick dude that's good man unironically
pulling up that is crazy bro oh my god You're in the limo,
bro?
Like, oh, this is nice.
Look at slime.
Look at slime just fucking chilling up there on top of the
limo.
They have the costumes we're using, too, because I always
use that color.
Wow, that's it.
This is us pulling up to Evo.
We should rent a limo.
Wow.
I'm fucking down.
i'm currently on top of the world all right fellas one more
set hey perhaps two one more perhaps two we're on top let's
just finish up oh they're about to do the interview let's
get them coach all right yeah coach gas us up fang way tell
them tell them how how we feel bro wait how do i counter sk
where where are my notes this coach bro i'm here i'm here
i'm here
occupied with the interview bro he's up here for the clout
it's hollywood everyone says he's hollywood now he switched
yeah i've been doing i get to be on sage upstream he let us
go come on now come on he's too hollywood he's actually too
hollywood that i know he said he'd give us notes and then he
did it it's true the video's real he's yeah i knew something
was up when he got
didn't keep got to his head he won two coaches matches and
now he thinks he's better than us hold on i i will dm sk ask
her to throw maybe it will help i mean they're already going
to evo what do they care right like you know yeah hello can
you throw for god damn it would be like the biggest
character arc for me it would be so good wait but imagine
the clips okay okay okay say say that we'll we'll win trade
we'll give joki the win and i'll trade i'll trade my fd win
you don't tell the world while all of us are streaming that
will win trade joki the win that will throw yep yes across
my heart hope to die i will literally i will play like shit
brain off moment we're doing we're doing business at the
table we're All of this is for content, right?
Just think about the clips.
He fucking proposed showing it on stream.
All I'm saying...
I gotta hear this interview.
All I'm saying is that if I win against SK, just imagine the
amount of views we're gonna get for both of us.
Oh, Lobby.
up oh all right on drawing ah bees up don't worry we'll edit
this out drawing post guys they'll never know they'll never
know there was match fixing
i like how the passwords are so complicated but we're all
showing it on stream
i don't have the elements like brawl pro i don't have a i
don't have a png to cover it actually covering it no no he
said i don't have the elements oh yeah it's true i cannot
cover it we can't cover it guys i don't have enough hard
drive space to make a png i don't know yeah i don't know how
to open up pinging
oh my god people are saying tone actually looks depressed
bro no no tone you should have studied up other people not
just us
you think about like when you get really good at the game
you're like oh they don't like complain about like cheese or
matchups or like they're like iron will and then you just
watch high level people play each other and they're just
like fucking dog shit who plays like that who fucking who
grabs there it's so funny you're like they're just like us
they're just like us
oh yeah we're waiting for our coaches oh this is cute this
is cute art
it's three kings oh my god guys it's all it's time the
finals we made it doesn't matter what happens we made it
guys we made it to the finals and that's all that matters no
matter what chat everybody will remember us
we will if we don't win we gaslight all the fans into
thinking we won and that's all that I thought they, I
thought this team won last time I actually legit thought
this team won last time so like the gaslighting worked we
can do it again because I'm a professional at this I don't
worry if we don't win We won.
Guys, remember, no matter what, we won the finals.
Okay, guys?
Always remember that.
We won the finals.
It's forgotten.
Oh.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Ish.
I'm not that nervous, though, because, like, I know my
place.
how does she do it guys i can't but guys we did it we won
the tournament guys we did it okay let's practice that chat
we gotta practice okay when we obviously no matter what when
we win how are you guys gonna react guys
oh my god guys we did it
Yeah, we gotta practice our celebration because we're gonna
celebrate winning no matter what happens chat We won no way
Reaction practice guys.
I need you guys to be more hype.
I need you guys to rewrite history for me chat How are you
gonna rewrite history if you're not as hype?
Let's go We're just waiting.
We're just waiting on our coaches to come back to us.
And then we can start.
Yay.
That's all we need to do.
We just need to wait for our coaches to come back to us.
Yay.
though he's tired guys it's been five hours we we've been
we've been techeting whoa we've been techeting for five
hours guys
yeah when are we starting they're having some giveaways
before they get started oh so they're still doing the
giveaway stuff my chat's practicing on celebrating no matter
what that's a good good community yeah they're gonna if we
lose they're gonna make sure everybody knows we won if we
lose we win if we win we win yeah it's literally impossible
so let's just let's just finish up yeah oh
i'm so happy i'm like relaxed i'm not nervous at all anymore
i'm I'm just relaxed and chill now.
I got what we wanted.
We made it so far.
So I'm not as...
I'm not nervous anymore.
I'm just here to vibe with my team.
I'm just happy.
Yippee.
And a little eepy.
Does that scare gonna do it?
I said I'll...
She wants something.
I said she can have my Chipotle code.
What if...
she's like what if she's manipulating you she's tricking you
no i'm too smart for that okay we gotta get a final answer
soon we can see it we can see it based on how she is yeah
yeah yeah she gotta make it look real though yeah make it
look real like how i'll make my loss look real yeah yeah
yeah she's gotta make it look real like if she starts
beating out of me then take that code back and the world
will know she's a liar that she wouldn't match fix for us
how could she
what did he did tone say ggs i hate you
sorry tone listen man ggs i hate you listen yeah look at my
chat uh matt if you see it i i mean i'm sure she's stream
open ha
sorry there was a copy pasta bro hold that hold that tone
i'll see you at eva dude
would a giveaway faster
matt your ass i didn't drop a single game Where is he typing
this?
He's already rewriting history.
Do I read your chat?
He said, Matt your ass, Brawl Pro, you're carried.
Oh!
Damn.
Can you let him say that to you?
It's okay.
It's okay, dude.
I just, I can't hear you all the way down there at third.
I hope you have to edit for six days.
Nope, I am taking a break.
I am shit.
Where's the lobby?
Who's lobby?
it uh it's in stage one fey posted it yeah yeah yeah wait he
posted that a while ago i'm not in there yet yeah i didn't
ready up don't worry coach i'm keeping them hostage for you
let's get it team if you win and it seems obvious i will
throw but if it seems no what the fuck shut up shut up shut
up time bro i'm not trying to lose an ad we're trying to get
some match fixing going on here for the content i'm readyed
up i saw bra pro and i'm fucking in yeah i'm in there is my
thumbnail that says that i won don't fuck this up for me the
fuck out of here you're free made your you pre-made your
thumbnail yeah you gotta post that regardless i got money
like that come on regardless of what happens you gotta post
that thumbnail I won parentheses, kind of.
Almost.
I won bracket baited.
On the thumbnail, like they didn't even click it yet.
Yeah, yeah, they didn't click.
Please click, I won, I swear.
You couldn't, you wouldn't believe this, guys, but I won.
Alright, let's see.
Alright, let's see, let's see how she plays.
Coach, you never told me, like, how to, like, what to do
about sk you never told me anything let's grip her up really
oh my god you're right she's scared bro just grab oh oh my
god you're right yep wait wait wait wait wait oh my goodness
oh what maybe not never mind you have not now you can just
punch maybe not maybe not
Oh my god, she's making it look real Oh wait, what the?
Oh, guys Guys?
Guys, she's not playing anymore She was like, fuck it, I
don't want this at all I hate that shit Yeah, we were just
fucking with you Oh my god, what a storm What the heck?
We were just messing our bounds Doki, Doki, holy...
Wait, maybe she is making it look real!
She's making it look so real!
God, no.
The fix?
The fix is in?
Wait, is it true?
Bro, bro, did you actually do it for us?
No, she's playing for real.
You got to.
Are you sure?
I thought you were throwing, to be honest.
Guys, I don't know what to do.
when she does that.
You do that.
Holy shit.
But...
She's so scared of you.
Why?
Because you're good!
You're fucking good!
Oh my.
Oh, okay.
No, no.
Guys, guys.
Wait, do I hit that?
No way.
No fucking way!
Can I get a yay in the chat?
Yay!
What the fuck?
The ESAM Slayer is down.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
If I...
It's okay.
It's over.
We're done.
The tournament.
Wait a minute.
You're killing it.
One more.
Just keep it up.
Keep it up.
taken let's go it's time to send in that chipotle code thank
you
one more one more all right i already got my one win i don't
care anymore no you care i should care a lot you care a lot
you care a lot wait what's in it for me well we're gonna win
we're gonna fucking win What a set, though!
I tried to do that thing you did, but it didn't work.
Guys, I think she, like, gave...
You didn't... You only told her to do one set, and she
wasn't...
Oh yeah, didn't you say throw a set?
Damn it.
Yeah.
God damn it!
Bro, pro!
You promised the whole set!
Oh, you're cooking.
You're cooking.
Am I?
Oh, my way.
No, go away.
Let's go.
You're actually a better player.
Am I?
Yes, you are.
She's so scared, Doki.
She's so scared.
Is she gone?
Josh is in the living room.
He just said, let's go, Doki.
He's screaming for me.
I'm not sure.
Everyone wants to get Doki.
Let's go, Doki.
SK plays the content would be so funny.
It really would.
It would be so good.
SK, just think about it.
Oh my god, the mid.
You mixed her.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
There's no way.
No.
Goodbye.
She's dead, right?
I'm dead.
No, I'm 100% dead.
Hey, you had that, Doki.
If you had that, Doki, that was all you.
Oh, you're alive.
Wait!
What do I do?
No!
There was nothing.
Close though, close though.
Oh, hello.
Let's fucking go.
Oh, hello!
Oh, she ducks now!
That's fine, that's fine.
So running me now.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Nice.
Oh my god!
different how do you get up how are you getting up fight
goodbye part one start come on yay oh my a clean hit dude no
i forgot to do that it's cool it's cool it's cool you're
cooking her am i yes you are yes you truly are the don't get
out of the rooting oh the counter hit
I got a point!
Let's fucking go!
Let's go, don't you?
Really?
Unbelievable.
Actually unbelievable.
Yeah!
Let's go, don't you?
We did it!
The alley kicks!
Oh my god!
Since I beat SK and SK beat at ESAM, I'm better than ESAM!
It's actually true.
We call that the mod a number in in melee we win these
that's actually insane I told you we don't need defense I
can't believe it
quick block block SK delete the It never happened.
It never happened.
Oh my god.
You are incredible.
I clutch it when it matters.
Oh my goodness.
That's my goat.
Oh my god.
He almost did a combo.
Nice dude.
Oh my god.
Oh, my god.
Nice!
King sweet!
Nice.
Good shit.
Hey, that was good.
Oh, Manesto.
What a duck, Cody.
Oh, nice.
Yee!
Don't hold forward after that, by the way.
No.
Oh, shit.
She's not gonna get her brother.
You don't know.
Oh That's a failure of these by the way.
Yeah, what the fuck you didn't you didn't teach that on you
buddy That's on you buddy.
We got three king players.
You didn't you didn't teach them how to get up properly
Nice Freaky king
That's my god Yes
Good shit.
I tried to alley kick that was good.
I'll give it that was good.
Yeah, that was good a strong player.
Oh This is truly finals.
Yeah, she saw it Nice good mid.
Okay.
All right.
Lock in formidable.
Yes, bro.
Oh my god She's attacking.
All right.
I got to lock in She's kind of killing it now.
Okay, okay.
Let's go, baby.
That's why I'm making it close.
Making it close.
Good.
Ugh.
She's gonna get it correctly now.
They're live coaching.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, you're right.
You're like coaching.
Yeah, so hit that alley kick after.
Yeah.
Oh my goodness.
He's dead.
That's counter hit.
Is he alive?
Oh.
Nice.
Dude, why you got a Looney Tunes bump on your head?
What is that?
That's Steve Austin, bro!
That's Stone Cold!
Yeah, it's bald like sayjamming.
It's bald, sayjamming.
Steve Austin, bro!
Looks like he has like a fucking pimple on his head.
The Looney Tunes injury.
The anvil?
y'all know about coney's p.m wario dude Oh p.m war yeah, we
go wario here.
Yeah p.m.
Wario bro wow
Okay Lock in brother.
Again She needs to do a crowd she gotta adapt Mario
Okay, she's waiting now, which means I'm bringing this like
you.
That's right.
That's that adaptation, brother.
Yep.
Oh my god.
That's right.
And you hit him with a break.
Give me the point.
Give me your points.
Yes.
Sweet the team.
She's scared now.
Now we run up grab.
Oh my god.
She's so scared.
You're predicting you're alive.
Oh my goodness.
No!
Counter hit everywhere.
Never let her get up!
Nice punish, Cody.
That's a punish.
The one, two?
That was a punish.
Now we fight.
Yeah, now we fight every time.
I get it.
I know how this game works.
Now we go.
Who is he?
He's starting to believe.
He moves like they do.
He's in her mind.
Good shit.
I hate this stage.
We just have to give her one, you know?
mid not these five how many walls are in this holy it's like
it's like an architect it's a temple it's okay two of them
are gone now so it's a bit bigger now
nice we're good we're good we're good man it's fine oh i
pressed it's all fine all good okay all right it's fine it's
fine good adaptation oh All right, I know what to do.
I just stagger offense.
Cool.
Nice.
Just grab and stagger on.
I caught it.
Oh my god.
Oh.
What else?
You still have smash though.
Yeah.
That's a win con.
And she's burning rage.
You don't have to worry about it.
Yeah.
She had a lot of gray life though.
So it's going to take that.
But other than that, you don't have to worry about it.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
One more mix.
She was in the air.
Oh, what a block by her.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I go to alley kick.
I went to alley kick.
I did down back three.
Oh, nice try.
Nice try.
I got to get off that stage.
I'm getting off there.
Very close.
Oh, it was a close.
It was close.
She's playing a lot, bro.
She got better.
Yeah, 100%.
Yeah, she's playing County King.
I just got to grab more.
I know the timing.
Yeah.
She doesn't tech.
She's barely been ducking either.
No, yeah.
All right, I got it.
I got it.
You just wanted to be a pretty king for a third round.
I got a good, uh, I got a good stage here.
Get ready for the next battle.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Come on, baby.
Is she scared at the start again?
That would be hilarious.
I could have just done the fucking pedigree again.
Okay.
Drop his wallet.
That's okay.
Oh, fuck, man.
I didn't know it was that punishable.
Nice.
Dude, that just locks me in.
It's okay.
Nice.
Nice hot kick, bro.
Guaranteed at the wall.
Uh-oh.
Wow.
An alley kick.
Nice.
about dude three alley kicks three kings nice good shit I
tried to go low Wow that break oh okay okay okay nice option
he's anxious nice got up wrong yep more mix more grabs oh
she got up way wrong You got up wrong, dude!
Oh!
End it, Kony.
Come on, Kony!
You got this, Kony!
Muscle Buster breaks the floor.
I know, I know.
He's watching.
Lil B is watching.
Oh, we fucked it up.
It's okay.
Yeah, you saw what I wanted.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, I'm too scared to lock!
Oh, my God.
I'm too scared to lock!
Hold on, hold on.
He's a bus ass.
Oh, he's fucking a muscle bus.
Nice, great games, great games, great games.
Oh, nice!
Oh, fuck, yeah, man.
Oh, yeah.
Cody, win.
Cody, let's go!
She got very good.
King sweep!
She wasn't playing really good.
Her composure has gotten so much better, dude.
I like, I kind of steamrolled her at certain points, but
like, there are other times that she took the game back from
me.
Okay, hey, bro, you're at PDX because I'm going to lose the
FT.
Dude, relax, you've got this.
Slime's turn.
Let's go slime, dude.
Slime, we got this.
Hey, slime, you could just end it right now.
Yeah, I can end it right now.
I could end it right now.
Do you want live coaching slime?
I mean, just tell me right now.
Yes.
Let's try it.
I think I know what I have to do.
Like, taunts while rage-guarding.
I think.
here we go what a day man I know dude I well what a day I'm
gonna fucking drink after this I actually need to chill the
brain Jesus who needs defense I'm here to represent all the
king players that don't block he's a real one all right
brother let's go round one fight
six nice stay composed time you can do these combos yeah
what the good this guy's
free to running one plus two he doesn't do anything at that
range
Bro, slime, I'm going to tell you the truth, dude.
I think he knows he has to win.
He's food.
He's insane.
He's going to be missing in the forest lady.
He's so scared.
He doesn't want to lose it.
Yeah, he wants to put the pressure on the other guy.
That's right.
Slime.
Oh.
God, eat him!
Eat him!
Eat the bird, too!
Eat the fucking bird!
No, no way.
I thought this guy was nice, bro.
What the fuck?
We let him get one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Damn, that's a lot, though.
That one is a lot.
No, we ducked that, we ducked that actually.
Oh, good spring kick!
Oh my god.
I think somebody really wants to win You have heat slime.
Oh big grab
The fuck is that?
What the fuck is that?
I can't believe he didn't turn it.
That's actually crazy He's desperate as fuck He's so
desperate slime Give us that live coaching bra bro He's
gonna shoulder you every time you do back one, you have to
stop.
Unless you think he's gonna hit, unless you think he's gonna
pressure you, then you have to do it, but he has the punish.
Yeah, back one as long as you don't think he's gonna block.
Nice.
Oh, that life's back.
That's a wall combo.
Nice!
Oh.
Get off the ground!
Fish!
Pressure.
Mix, mix, mix!
What's that?
Rage art!
That's...
That's so close.
That's just gonna kill you.
Oh, it's so close.
In that situation, the hunter hunting bear stance 1 plus 2
would have worked, where you're in hunting and you back off.
It would have worked.
Yeah.
And if you did your wall...
When I said wall combo, you did it.
the wall combo there i mean he was dead yeah i thought i
couldn't because i blew my like i thought i blew something
that's fine you did your heat burst but that's fine they can
still do it and also when you got a wall spot you did g clef
and then you tried to do the back three plus four that's not
going to work because g clef counts as my tornado yeah so if
you g class at one if you g clef tornado then you can do
down back one plus two spam okay uh that the wall combo you
got this dude you already know what to do also when you get
mid-range he's free to while running one plus two round one
fight where's hot kick set
stop that's crazy man i can't believe that's crazy you got
this dude yeah only back one for the for the moves to nice
that's shit back two to one back two to one and then do it
again after the tornado that's fine too yeah whatever smack
edge nice nice that's a reset you can back to one do you
regular combo yeah a forward to ray burst of heat
nice bro nice good shit oh beautiful
that's okay dude just focus you got it fight that was i mean
like good you are the bear player good man slime we believe
what the micro okay i didn't mean to do that dude this lag
sucks it's okay it's weird oh
it's just so fucking laggy yeah team lag team lag joke of
the game dude yeah oh that's okay that's okay it's okay i'm
about to fight fd on the microwave you know like it's like
why
they needed one it's okay matt matt's gonna fucking take it
home for us three straight would have been a little
embarrassing for them yeah yeah yeah that's true
save me 58 defense save me 58 defense jack i will try dude
get his ass he's got three characters well he's got two he's
not gonna play jack but he's going eddie brother yeah i will
try i don't know bro just get ready to play he he shut up
bro win the tournament now yeah we got you got this guy
plays on a ds i swear to god i i feel the prince this guy's
playing eddie bro prayed jack jesus right now chat get the
prayers going in oh you just have to be offensive until you
think he's gonna power crush then you have to launch that
offend him round one
infinite he hasn't learned oh he doesn't know how to get up
or i would have taught him i would have taught it bro if he
was on the squad
he's so freaky oh my god i don't know what character does
dude i'm literally just playing outfield we'll try Got it.
It's all good.
It's only one.
Wow.
Round three.
That's a third hit.
Nice.
He's got guns.
He's still alive.
I know that's fucking launch.
What a block, man.
Good fucking block.
What a read.
Come on, baby.
Oh, fuck.
I wanted to dump for two.
It's okay, you got the set.
Fight.
That's launch.
Scarecrow three.
Great job, Jab.
That's launch.
He's dead.
Uh oh.
They're doing wall carry.
Why did I get the god wall?
I don't know.
Thank you.
That's insane.
Oh my god.
Wall to wall?
Oh my god!
God wanted us to win!
God's favorite player.
He gave it to you.
Check out Mad Freaky.
happy Sunday everybody it is his day I can't believe he got
that wall I was thinking about it and and dude the God I was
like okay maybe he's gonna stay on the ground because this
is gonna whiff I gotta plant the seeds not just clean splat
that's crazy get ready for the next battle Phew.
Round one.
Oh my god, he doesn't know that.
Eddie.
Boom.
One.
One, one, he won.
One, one.
That's my goat.
Come on, Eddie, you have to use other numbers.
Oh.
fucking out of here kick man that dodge though in the
beginning where's the dizzameter where's this i know his ass
is dizzy as hell he's nauseous no way we spring kick oh my
god that's nice punish oh my god that was cool send the
rocket oh drop spot you got him drop One more, brother.
I'm fucking going!
The cross from space!
Break, check, free!
Oh, no, fate!
Oh, I swear to God it lagged.
I swear to God it lagged.
It's cool, bro.
We bouncing here.
Oh, my God, your feet.
It was fate.
We had to end the tournament this way.
Put him away, Jack.
Come on, Jack.
Oh, my God, no.
It's all good.
It's fine, bro.
We believe in you.
Oh Come on, it's Sunday It's Sunday This is your day Oh,
that's a punish, but he's not dead.
Oh, it's counter hit.
No, it's not counter hit No way the tournament ends here.
That'd be insane All right, oh my goodness That's it
Jesus Jesus Jesus My savior My ass This is a new fucking
game I'm installed now Holy shit man Many blessings Fuck you
Many blessings upon all chats He is risen once more oh my
dude we got first what the fuck you did it man the dokey
diff again ironically oh my god i clutched it when it
matters i can't believe it i can't believe it bravo did not
have to play it's just like the slam all over again he can
rest he can't ask me for an exhibition i'm about to say No.
Pop it, bro.
Come on.
Do an exhibition.
Let's do take a ball.
Take a ball.
Do it.
It's worth nothing.
Get in there.
Your team already won.
I want to see you play again for the road.
I'm trying to see you play one more time.
For the homies.
Do it for the family.
No pressure.
Not that just.
Let's get it.
The after party, bro.
King.
They want to ban King.
I'm just right on it.
Well, three kings winning.
Well, well, well.
What up team Brawl Pro?
Hi.
Oh, I see him.
Hey.
What's good?
Can I just say congratulations to Doki for winning a trophy?
Let's fucking.
Oh, true.
That's for one person.
I have a 30 on defense.
Wait, you actually clutched up big time against us.
She did really well.
She did.
She really fucking did, dude.
That was on how many I feel like you've been putting in the
night shift is that is that the case like Doki's the late
night tech and grinder Yeah, I'm the late night tech and
grinder.
I only play tech in that night I look it's like 2 a.m.
And you're like yo BP you up Like you know, like that Yo,
what's good?
And then he's just like I'll get out of bed like I'll pull
up what's good I've been very impressed Uh, but I was gonna
say congrats to all of your team you all played very very
well I'm impressed with your performance Uh, first time that
we didn't see brawl pro have the clutch it up too i know
that's wrong actually because i had to get stony you
remember oh i know that's what i'm saying you didn't have to
play this the first time you did oh he had to win oh yeah
yeah sorry he had to win so many high pressure sets dude he
had to get us to the finals but then we finish it off for
him memories of slam one yeah uh yeah i was gonna say i was
gonna ask for all of you um how how is his coaching style
what do you like about being on brawl pro's team can you
fucking answer me yeah i don't know why he does that to matt
only yeah that's kind of weird it feels kind of personal oh
man that guy knows i'll just leave him alone like he leaves
me alone he thinks i'll figure it out myself i don't
understand but you know what he was right so he must be
goaded you're the oldest child like you don't need as much
help as us you know what i mean like he just gives you your
own designs you're the oldest you have to take care of our
help man
locked in Matt you played really yeah I know like today
especially I feel like you were pretty solid looking at
every single set that I saw you play so yeah I played Tekken
until 7 a.m last minute because I was like there's no way
I'm fucking losing yeah and we covered like Alyssa and stuff
but not Zaf I don't think I I encountered a Zafina a Supreme
Zafina who I was just doing like a ranked grind like I kept
queuing into her at 7 a.m.
like constantly and that was my practice I got lucky yeah i
was also gonna say so uh doki are you are you coming to evo
maybe i really appreciate you playing in the tournament
regardless it's very nice of you to do so if you want to
come uh you know let me know i'd appreciate it yeah they are
asking for a coach match if you guys want to pull up do it
do it do it i was gonna say evo offered to fly the first and
you're cool with it and evo doesn't mind if you want to pass
your trip down to second place i will fly out third place
instead well i don't know we gotta think about it you know
what i'm talking about a per diem lobster dinner yeah i
think we get a per diem instead yeah yeah our evil budget
okay let me just yeah tony tony they said they said go fuck
yourself yeah you got I can still go, right?
Can I still go?
No, they said it would have been down to until Tony said, at
your ass.
So no, the orphans, no, not them either.
The orphans can't come.
Yeah, sorry.
So I got off the phone with Tony.
Seems understandable.
I'm down with that.
I guess I lost it for all of us, guys.
None of us are going to evil.
This is so sad.
Sorry, guys.
So, you know, thanks to all of you for playing, by the way.
I really, really appreciate it.
Thanks for having us.
Yeah, I'd love to do another.
If you ever do another Seijab slam, I'd love to join again.
It's been so fun.
No way.
Yeah, absolutely.
Good luck in your coaches match.
Why the fuck are you on Kuma?
Wait, he's playing Kuma.
Why the hell is this dude on Kuma?
Because Kuma's the goat.
Uh oh, big ass bear.
Watch out.
Oh my god.
Uh oh.
I played Fee with King twice already in both round robins.
Get him on.
He wouldn't expect it.
Broke him play a cat and a bear.
He's got a destruction bear, man.
joke.
Jesus Christ, that sounded like it hurt.
Yeah, you heard that shit?
Like a gunshot.
Spike to the ground, man.
Uh-oh.
Hit him with a cool move, coach.
Oh.
Do a cool move.
Yeah, do a cool move.
Coach, get up.
Do it.
Come on.
Do the move.
No.
Maybe we should have gone kick, coach.
Where's the king?
Go Paul.
Oh my god.
Please go Paul.
Oh shit.
Congress in the universe.
Yeah.
I haven't played Paul in like two months.
I don't care bro.
Kick his ass.
Yeah.
He's only taking God supreme.
Let's do a cool move.
Yeah.
Oh.
Dude the alley kicks up before Kuma.
Oh, that's good.
Oh, that's a fast move.
No way we go.
Okay.
Oh, got one move.
He does.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Coach, come on!
Oh, that's kind of pretty.
I like that.
Got her.
She got flowers on her shoulder.
Oh, nice!
Timing missile.
Do you think that thing tastes good?
We're gonna roast that.
Watch this mix.
Maybe I'm just hungry.
We've been playing Tekken for six hours.
Actually, I'm fucking starving.
What the fuck?
Respectfully, Coach, I'm gonna need you to lock in.
yeah coach i mean there we go yeah yeah oh one there that
move is silly such good wall running inputs he does it on a
lever too how does he do it let's see paul allen's lever oh
no way they gave him that one that wall is bugging me pretty
hard it's the fee difference oh the back to one perfectly
all right are you hitting me oh no oh no hit her one time
coach hit her one time coach well actually this isn't even
your main so you would have yeah yeah that's fine you almost
beat her you almost beat them exactly that's just
embarrassing for them yeah i want to try so hard that was so
close on kuma I don't know.
And bear...
Come on.
You have to play until we get another set.
You gotta play king so we can get another set.
There's nothing wrong with bear.
You could play the bear.
I'll let you play bear.
Come on.
I do support bear, to be fair.
I'll support bear.
You've earned it, bro.
You've earned it.
Play who you want, bro.
Play who you want.
You're asking for a Paul, but I would, but I just haven't
played him like two months.
Make them play a different character.
He's so scared.
You are scared to play ball.
And that's, dare I say, pathetic.
That's a moral failing.
Yeah.
No, I want to play King.
He's fun.
There you go.
Sit up your cell phone.
But we blocked that.
What's the cool combo?
Do the really cool showcase combo.
Kind of boring, coach.
Mm-hmm.
Let's do a cool thing.
Oh, that's pretty cool.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
They bounce?
What do we do?
We do some cool fun.
Fuck optimization.
I was optimal.
That actually, yeah, that was fucking.
Oh, I'm saying, you fuck optimization.
Show me some cool shit.
Yeah, show me all the cool combos.
That could never do.
Oh, wow.
Timeout?
Whoa, whoa.
this is chess oh oh let's go let's go but three percent
bro do the wall jump again that was so cool that was not
happening again do the wall jump do the wall jump get the
spider-man uh-oh no way he does it three times right can you
can you giant swing pdx three times yeah in a row like don't
do anything else but yeah not do it again I don't think he's
gonna work pdx bro just bro he's trying his hard out right
now no he isn't gonna be able to talk after this her brain
is just pacing to her skull fight bro bro is being audio
terrorized oh he took damage okay all right i see coach we
condition two to then do one truly oh wow oh wow bro if he
might be the goat i might have a new coach next slam wait
he's kind of i wonder if he could teach me lily bravo you
really got that led coach cody Oh, this is it.
Tony, you made him mad.
You made our coach mad.
Look at him.
Now he's taking it out on her.
I'm not mad.
Coach, you're the only one for me.
Oh, staying over the sprint deck.
Are you crazy?
I don't know why that worked.
Break her arm, coach.
And then they don't see no death crater.
Okay, how long is this?
That's the last.
Actually, go for RDC.
I'm not kidding.
Do the RDC.
They would never expect it.
something cool yeah you've made me remove my rdc binds or
can't reach rdc bind yeah i had rdc bind he made me remove
it because he wants it i could see it i see him fishing he
wants it so bad oh how do we lock it in how do we lock it in
oh oh what the
a lot of kids oh that is how a true champion fights for the
one time hit the rdc though yeah yeah yeah for the one time
yeah his ass will break it come on it's all the two you
think he knows that but yeah but he wanted for the content
but what if you start to break something else because he's
like no way no if he gets old fidex will never live that
down even for content there is no way he's not pressing two
he's taking off this guys yeah he's gonna get his drop
sponsor they're gonna call you it's in his contract he's
like never get rdc'd had to press two dude is it to once bro
fire how about a mushroom can't stop me
I'm not New York City.
Pizza Man.
There's a fucking cheetah in town square.
This bloody cheetah is harassing me.
Where's the bobbies?
Just put a cheeky pine at the pub.
Where's the bobbies in this lot?
This bloke just poked me in my toes.
Oh, I have some fucking chips up in this, I will.
Oh, she's playing it.
Oh, that cheeky cat.
That cheeky cat.
Oh, bloody hell.
Me back.
Why are you mashing, Fee?
What are you doing?
That's meaty.
RDC.
At least go for it.
Come on, go for it.
Keep him honest.
You got to keep him honest about it.
Yeah.
Oh, he was.
I see it.
Yeah, he's like, okay.
Two.
Okay.
All right.
You tried.
We tried.
We take those.
You're welcome.
Oh.
Bro, with the bare feet too.
should have let him already seed bro bro he should have let
you already seed i would have let it happen yeah oh it's
okay you don't need that chipotle sponsor that is absurd
chip dude that is crazy oh my god yeah That's crazy.
Even.
Round four.
One, two, three.
At least Ali click kick to the end.
Oh my God.
Oh, that was, what, what move was that?
How come he knew that, but he didn't teach the players.
Yeah.
He ain't, he didn't teach nobody that.
He's saving it for nationals.
Well, just did it jump in like he's Ryu.
I didn't do that.
That was a, that was literally an anime fighter.
What the fuck?
Oh my God.
Ali kick, Ali kick, Ali kick.
Ali kick, Ali kick.
He's dead.
Goodbye.
Send him to the police.
Come in the cop car.
Take him away, boys.
Well done.
We dominated everyone.
We win.
We're the best.
We're the ghosts.
Best team.
Best vibes.
Best fan art.
Best fans.
Best team.
We actually did it, guys.
We didn't have to go to the coach's match for the
tiebreaker.
Takud ball.
World finals.
Oh, good shit, guys.
Oh, my God.
Jeez, everybody.
We fucking did it, man.
We fucking did it.
We got first place.
I love you guys, dude.
Seriously.
Oh, unbelievable, man.
I want the ghost of Super to come like Anakin's dad.
I'm going to go in Super's chat and be like, guess what?
we got first
oh unbelievable man good shit guys straight up wow oh my god
we got little say jam controllers again oh we got the first
right in the shit up man yeah look at the first place ones
this time true bro we got two controllers wait oh my god my
chat is saying all five of you raid super no no that would
be really funny hey little bro where were you why were i i
weren't you training sk earlier oh true
oh my god ggs guys what an experience ggs first fucking
place team brawl pro continues to be on top no matter what
no one expected us to take it to the first but here we are
um when i saw that Tony's team because they beat us for one
right yeah it was bad it was brutal but you guys put in so
much freaking work man yeah we literally put them on tilt
too yeah yeah yeah yeah we put them on tilt so we get the
free PDX win nope no offense but you know like let's be
honest like let's be honest that shit was kind of easy we
did it no well I mean look fang way no no your your seat is
fucked honestly like i don't believe you yeah yeah dude yeah
you had roy you had that bang player i you had your roommate
your best friend whatever that was up dude you got the third
seat was literally fucked up like yeah it was insane not not
not a usu genuinely oh we did it bro well i i yeah i'm
actually gonna well they said that you can stay in the
discord and we're gonna hang out so i would stay in the yeah
um you know how late night in this discord people are
hanging out it's always Yeah, come check out the discord
because we literally just sit and we just talk like everyone
comes in.
Oh, that sounds neat I'll probably pop in I'm hungry, bro.
Yeah, I'm gonna fucking smoke a doobie and then get some
jack-in-the-box Good fucking night.
You earned it, bro.
You earned it.
That's that's an American recent That's I'm literally
American recent.
You earned him at six hours of Tekken.
You deserve it, man You all you you're all fucking amazing
GG.
I could not ask for a better team once again but he had a
great time i'm so happy you guys at evo man yeah we got the
evo let's get food good guys good all right see you guys we
gotta oh god i'm sad yeah over the school year over the
school year stay in touch it's so sad man all right all
right next stage i'm sam guys street fighter we all get
together again i'm in there i'm entering that for sure same
dude All right, I'll see you later, guys.
All right, bye, guys.
Bye-bye.
Cheers.
Oh, my God.
I, honestly, I did not expect to win against SK because SK
won against ESAM.
And then I did not know what the fuck ESAM was doing with
ESAM.
So I was so surprised.
I can't believe I won against SK.
I told guys I told you all I need to do was just nothing the
moment I stopped thinking like it works it just works my
brain I don't know what if I don't know what I'm doing she
doesn't know what I'm doing so she's confused and I'm
confused and then I won oh my god I can't believe it we
clutched it We might have lost the other games today, but we
won the finals match, which matters the most, because that
meant Brawl Pro didn't have to do the final coach in the
fight.
Once I relaxed, I started fucking.
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
I'm so, so, so happy, guys.
I'm really happy with this team.
It was such a great team.
Brawl Pro was actually, despite how much we roast Brawl Pro,
it was a great coach.
He taught me those six moves, the six most important moves
ever to get me here.
If it weren't for those six moves and that alley kick, I
would not have been here.
But thank you guys for cheering us on.
this was such a great team i love this team so much um i
couldn't have asked for a better group of people to vibe
with um honestly thank you guys for cheering us on what a
fucking arc for me fighting game arc we had there um the
fact that we went from zero fighting game experience um with
only like 50 hours played um started off started training
late later than all the other
gamers that were in my seat, I trained, I started training a
week late, uh, because I was so busy, so, um, and then had
the, and then had the fucked up PC until I fixed it the last
day.
Like, my PC was so fucked until I fixed it today for just
this tournament, and we managed to clutch it.
I'm so happy.
I'm really, really happy.
um but yes thank you everybody i'm gonna rest now haven't
had dinner yet and we train for six hours and we grind we
played techin for six hours and i trained yesterday for so
long too i mean i got i ranked up last night because i was
just like training and rank and and i'm just so happy it's
over oh thank you everybody for watching as always everyone
say hydrated posture check get up and we're around to get
that blood flowing and if you stood up for me head to bed
because you deserve I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.